AFTERNOON EVERYONE WELCOME TO
THE APRIL TWENTY EIGHTH HEARING
OF THE ASSEMBLY'S
ACCOUNTABILITY AND MINISTER OF
REVIEW COMMITTEE AS WE WAIT FOR
MEMBERS TO JOIN US WE'LL GO
AHEAD AND BEGIN THIS HEARING AS
A SUB COMMITTEE I BEFORE WE
JUMP INTO OUR BUSINESS LET ME
JUST ADDRESS A COUPLE OF HOUSE
KEEN EYED HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS DO
YOU TO THE PANDEMIC WE CONTINUE
TO PRACTICE PHYSICAL DISTANCE
IN HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM AND
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL BUILDING.
SO WE ARE ONLY ABLE TO HAVE A
LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE WATCH
AND PARTICIPATE IN THE HEARING
IN PERSON. WE ARE ALSO
REQUIRING THAT MASKS BE WORN
AND PHYSICAL DISTANCING
MAINTAINED BY ALL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TESTIFYING WEATHER
HERE IN THE ROOM OR AT A VIDEO
CONFERENCING SITES. IF YOU DO
NOT HAVE A MASK WE CAN PROVIDE
ONE FOR YOU. WE HAVE A FEW
DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR WITNESS
TESTIMONY TODAY IF ANY MEMBER
OF THE PUBLIC HERE IN THE ROOM
WITH LIKE TO TESTIFY ON A BILL.
PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND AND I
WILL ASK YOU TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. AT REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATIONS ARE LOCATED OUTSIDE ON
THE NORTH SIDE OF THE CAPITOL.
THE STATIONS ARE AVAILABLE FOR
PRIMARY WITNESSES AS WELL AS-
ME TO WITNESSES. FOR DIALING
WITNESSES WE WILL BE USING A
MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE
THROUGH WHICH ANY WITNESS CAN
TESTIFY ON ABOUT THE CALL IN
NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN YOU CAN
ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
ASSEMBLY ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ADMINISTER FREEVIEW COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IF YOU ARE CALLING IN
PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE AS WE HAVE ONLY A
LIMITED NUMBER OF BILLS ON
TODAY'S AGENDA. IF YOU ARE
CALLING INDUSTRY MINOR TO
ELIMINATE YOUR BACKGROUND NOISE
I WHICH INCLUDES MEETING YOUR
LIVESTREAM BROADCAST AND SMART
DEVICES TO REDUCE ANY SOUND
DISTORTION. IF YOU HAVE ANY
PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATED
PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE AT. 916-319-3680 AND
MY STAFF WILL BE THERE TO HELP
I ALSO DO WANT TO NOTE THAT WE
ARE ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY
THROUGH THE POSITION LETTER
PORTAL ON THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. I FOR THE BILLS BEING
TAKEN UP TODAY WE WILL TAKE NO
MORE THAN TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT AND TO MY PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. THESE
WITNESSES WILL HAVE TWO MINUTES
TO PROVIDE THEIR TESTIMONY ALL
SUBSEQUENT WITNESSES SHOULD
JUST STATE THEIR NAME AND THEIR
ORGANIZATION AND THEIR POSITION
ON THE BELT ONLY. I WOULD LIKE
TO NOTE THAT AB FORTY NINE. S.
HAS BEEN PULLED FROM TODAY'S
HEARING. AND FINALLY WE HAVE
FOR BILLS ON OUR PROPOSED
CONSENT CALENDAR FOR TODAY.
FILE ITEM ONE AB THIRTEEN
TWENTY THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CHIU. FILE ITEM Q. AB FOURTEEN
TWENTY NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
HOLDEN. AND FILE ITEM THREE AB.
FIFTY TO FIFTEEN SEVENTY ONE
WHICH IS A JEDI COMMITTEE FELL.
I DO NOT HAVE QUORUM SO AS I
SAID WE WILL BEGINNING WE WILL
BEGIN AT AS A SUB COMMITTEE AND
ACTUALLY BEFORE WE GET STARTED
I DO WANT TO JUST. WELCOME OUR
NEW CONSULTANT JESSE CUEVAS TO
OUR COMMITTEE FOR HIS DEBUT
HEARING CITED TO HAVE YOU ON
THE TEAM. OPERATE WITH THAT I'M
I BELIEVE WILL GET STARTED
WITH. I AGENCY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FONG I DO SEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BETH HELLO. WHENEVER YOU ARE
READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR-
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE WHO
ARE WATCHING. YEAH I WOULD LIKE
THAT I THINK YOU I AM HERE AND.
RIGHTS AND ADVISORY. AN
ADVISORY BOARD TASKED WITH
REVIEWING THE STATUS OF HUMAN
RIGHTS ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
CURRENTLY THERE IS NO FORMAL
STATE ENTITY THE FLAGS HUMAN
RIGHTS ABUSE HUMAN RIGHTS
ABUSES CONCERNS OUR
SHORTCOMINGS. ON THE CONTRARY
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
AND NONPROFITS NONPROFITS
TYPICALLY HAVE BEEN THE ONES TO
RAISE THESE CONCERNS. HOWEVER
BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC'S
ECONOMIC IMPACT ON THEM
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
AND NONPROFITS. MIGHT NOT BE
ABLE TO CONTINUE TO FULFILL
THIS ROLE. COUPLED WITH A
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT
PANDEMIC HAS HAD ON
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES. THE
NEED TO ENSURE RECOVERY IS DONE
IN AN EQUITABLE MANNER AND THAT
MOVING FORWARD THE HUMAN RIGHTS
OF ALL ARE PROTECTED IS OF
UTMOST IMPORTANCE. AB FOR
TWELVE WOULD CENTRALIZE THE
CONVERSATIONS ON HUMAN RIGHTS
AND BRING TOGETHER LEADERS
EXPERTS AND LEGISLATORS TO
EXAMINE THE STATUS OF HUMAN
RIGHTS AND PRODUCE REGULAR
REPORTS THAT CAN BE UTILIZED TO
GUIDE THE POLICY. HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. ARE AMBER
RECEIVED FROM CARE CALIFORNIA
AND JOSEPH SWIPES FROM SAN
FRANCISCO COMMISSION ON HUMAN
RIGHTS. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER S. OUT MODERATOR WE
PLEASE CONNECT US WITH A
MARRIAGE SHEET- WHO IS JOINING
US FROM THE COUNCIL ON AMERICAN
ISLAMIC RELATIONS. WELL I NEVER
OPENED WITH THE HEAD. I THANK
YOU CHAIRED MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR TIME TODAY I
THINK YOU MAJORITY LEADER RAY
AS IN YOUR LEADERSHIP AROUND
HUMAN RIGHTS FOR OFFERING THIS
CRITICAL BILL. MY NAME IS AMBER
SHE THAT I AM THE GOVERNMENT
AND LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS MANAGER
AT THE COUNCIL ON AMERICAN
ISLAMIC RELATIONS ARE CARE
CALIFORNIA. THE LARGEST LOCAL
RIGHTS ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION IN
THE COUNTRY AND WE ARE PROUD TO
BECAUSE SPONSORS OF THE- DID
OUR BELIEF THAT CAR. CENTERING
HERE RIGHTS AND THE MOST
MARGINALIZED IN OUR STATE ARE
IMPERATIVE TO ENSURE WE ARE
ADEQUATELY LIFTING THE DIVERSE
POPULATION ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
WE'D LOVE TO ILLUSTRATE OUR THE
TYPE CITY BUT WHAT CALIFORNIA
WORKS HARD TO WRAP. SERVICE ALL
THESE POP IN THE LOTTERY IF
NEED TO OUR RIGHTS WE THAT. THE
NEW OUT OF COMMUNITIES AND IS
UNDOUBTEDLY THROUGH THE-
GRADING GAP REPRESENTATION AND
CONCERNS THE STOCK OF RIGHT FOR
CERTAIN. OR ISSUE. AB FOR
TWELVE WITH AN OFFER. FOR
PARTNERSHIP AND DIE ACROSS THE
STATE AND THE KEY ADVISER ROLE
IN IDENTIFY GIFT. AND THE
RIGHTS HUNDRED. FOR THE BOOK
MARGINAL IT. WHETHER IT'S IN
THE WRONG OF EDUCATIONAL. HELD
BACK BRIDGE. OR NEARLY OUT OF
OTHERS RIGHTS ISSUE AREAS.
HAVING A DEDICATED. TO REVIEW
AND I. PRESS ISSUE THAT ARE OFF
OVERLOOKED WE COULD IN NATURE
THE WORLD FIFTH FLOOR ECONOMY.
AND LEADER EVEN RIGHTS. THE IS
NO ENTITY WITHIN THE YOU CAN BE
GAP PAUL OR IF THAT YOU'RE-
WITH SPECIFICALLY HE RIGHTS
HUNDRED APPROACH. AND THEN IN
TURN PROVIDE HUMAN ARE POLICY
SOLUTION PART TO. CALIFORNIA
MOST MARTIAL OR FOR TO BE AND I
THINK OF A BETTER. WITH THE
GROWING. AROUND RACE AND THE
RIGHT THE INDIVIDUALS ACROSS
THE- CALIFORNIA CREATE A- TO
BRING TOGETHER CAN YOU EXPERTS
TO PHONE. ON THE- AFTER. OF
RIGHTS ALL. IT'S FOR THE
REASONS I RESPECT URGE AIBO AND
THANK FOR YOUR TIME TODAY.
THANK YOU. AT MODERATOR PER.
CAN YOU CAN US WITH TWO SETS.
ARE WHO JOINING US THE SAMPLE.
RIGHT COMMISSION. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU CHAIR AND
MEMBERS FOR TIME AND THANK YOU
MAJORITY LEADER REYES MY NAME
IS JOSEPH THE NIGHT OF THE PLAY
OF SERVING AS VICE OF THIS
FRANCISCO HUMOUR COMMISSION.
HAS BECOME ODDS BEEN ABLE TO
WHAT FIRST THE INCREDIBLE WERE
THAT IS RIGHTS FOCUS CAN
ACHIEVE WHAT AM GOVERNMENT FIVE
TO IT ENACT IN THIS. IN FACT
THE FIFTH DIFFICULT FOR HEALTH
SAFETY AND A CON THE S. H. HAD
BEEN IN VALUE PART AND JEFF.
STAFF WERE INTEGRAL TO CITY'S
COMING CENTER ENSURE THAT
STATUE PAUL THAN WERE VIEWED
WITH AN ACT LAUGH THIS IS ONE
OF THE REASONS SEVERANCE WAS A
MY CITY FOR THE REST OF THE NAY
AND COVER RESPONSE. CITY WIDE
WORK DEVELOPMENT GREAT AND FUND
INITIALLY FOR BY PARKING L. Q.
CAN THANK YOU WERE MECHANISM
ARE JUST SOME OF THE EXAMPLES
OF THE HRC SCOPE THE STATE'S
BEYOND ITS INVESTIGATORY
MEDIATION FUNCTIONS THIS
CRITICAL WORK WELL INVALUABLE
AN EXHAUSTIVE IT'S NOT ENOUGH
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL CONVERSATION
CENTERING HUMAN RIGHTS AND HOW
WE CONTINUE TO UP TO LIFT THE
MOST VULNERABLE POPULATIONS IN
OUR STATE. ARE BECOMING
INCREASINGLY COMPLEX
UNNECESSARY AB FOR TWELVE WOULD
PROVIDE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
INCREASED PARTNERSHIP AND
DIALOGUE ACROSS THE STATE AND
SERVE AS A KEY ADVISORY ROLE TO
THE STATE ESPECIALLY WHEN WE
SEE HOW COLD IT CLIMATE CHANGE
AND OTHER ISSUES
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTS ARE
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS. A
STATEWIDE ENTITY POPULATED BY
EXPERTS AND COMMUNITY MEMBERS
TO TARGET THESE ISSUES AS THEY
ARISE WILL BENEFIT ALL
RESIDENTS AND BUSINESSES S. H.
R. C. IS ALREADY IN
COLLABORATION WITH SISTER
AGENCIES THAT SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA NEW YORK AND BEYOND
BUT WITH A STATE BODY THIS WORK
THE PARTNERSHIPS AND SUBJECT
MATTER EXPERTISE WOULD ONLY
STRENGTHEN AND BETTER SERVE OUR
LEGISLATURES LOCALLY AND
NATIONALLY. THAT'S WHY THE CITY
OF SAN FRANCISCO OUR STATE
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE HAS
FORMALLY TO SUPPORT AB FOR
TWELVE ANDERSON. IN HONOR THE
CALLER TODAY AND I RESPECT URGE
YOUR AYE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU MISTRESS WITH.
AND AT MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN UP
THE CALIFORNIA FOR AT. SUPPORT
OR UP TO. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
AND YOU MAY ONE AND THEN. ZERO
ONE AND THEN APPEARANCE. WITH A
LINE OF TWO SEVENTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS PICKED A
RESPONSIVE POLICY ADVOCATE WITH
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY THE PRODUCT BOXES
BUDGET THANK YOU. THANK YOU
DON'T KNOW ABOUT LINE OF EIGHT
YOUR IS OPEN. YOUR MARIN
MEMBERS ACTUALLY THE INJURED ON
THE OF OUR AND YOU SEE
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE- IN THE.
THANK YOU. AND NEXT TO A VOTE
TO THE LINE OF. TWENTY FIFTY
ONE TWENTY FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
MADISON BILL CLARK WITH THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
CALLING SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AND NEXT TO. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. NXR GONNA GO TO
LINE UP BUT TWENTY SEVENTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. DEGREE
COMMITTEE NOT ON BEHALF OF THE
COALITION FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT
RIGHT IN SUPPORT OF AB FOR
TWELVE. THANK YOU AND WE HAVE
NO MORE IN SUPPORT IN Q. OF
EIGHT AT MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINE FOR ANY
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU IF YOU'RE
IN OPPOSITION OF AB FOR TWELVE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
YOUR WITNESS PUSHING THE NUMBER
HERE LINE IS OPEN. HELLO YOU
HAVE YES YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
EIGHT ONE DON'T DENY YOUR OWN.
OKAY THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND
WE HAVE NO FURTHER- OPPOSITION
IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
IS THERE ANYONE WISHING TO
TESTIFY AND EITHER SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION VIA REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION AT THIS TIME. A RIGHT
C. NINE IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
HEARING ROOM WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN EITHER SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
FIGHT SCENE NINE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
ALL RIGHT WELL I THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR BRINGING ON
THIS SIDE MEASURE FORWARD AS WE
HAVE DICUSSED I ACTUALLY SHARE
YOUR BIGGER GOALS AND
OBJECTIVES AND I'M VERY HAPPY
TO HAVE A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION ON THE PROPOSAL-
AS WE NOTED IN THE ANALYSIS AND
INTIMIDATE THE AMENDMENTS- THAT
THAT YOU DID EXCEPT. BOB I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US TO
UNDERSTAND HOW THIS FIVE
COORDINATES AND WORKS IN
CONJUNCTION WITH EXISTING
COMMISSIONS AND EXISTING
INITIATIVES ACROSS THE STATE
AND TO ENSURE THAT THERE'S
CLARITY OF PURPOSE AND
OBJECTIVE- SO LOOK FOR TO
CONTINUING THOSE CONVERSATIONS
AS THAT AS THE BILL MOVES
THROUGH THE PROCESS BUT HAPPY
TO- TO SUPPORT IT TODAY IN
COMMITTEE AN ACTUAL BEFORE WE
VOTE I'M GOING TO TAKE A MOMENT
TO ESTABLISH QUORUM SECRETARY
CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
PETRIE-NORRIS. PRESENT
PETRIE-NORRIS PRESENT PATTERSON.
BURKE BURKE PRESIDENT RAY.
LACKING HERE LACKEY PRESIDENT.
MEDINA THE DELIVER THEM
PROBABLY. THANK YOU GREAT SO WE
DO HAVE A QUORUM AND FIVE. WITH
THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER RATES
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE. SECRETARY CAN PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
PETRIE-NORRIS. I DON'T THINK
THAT WAS THE MOST. OVERSIGHT
YOU SO MUCH. YES WITH THAT HAVE
A MOTION IN THIS. AND WE ARE
READY TO PLEASE THE ROLL THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED.
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS. THREE NORRIS
HI PETRIE-NORRIS HI PATTERSON.
BURKE BURKE I GRADE. LACKEY
LACKEY I MEDINA MEDINA I
RODRIGUEZ. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
AT THAT BILL IS OUT AND WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR OTHER
MEMBERS TO ADD ON THANK YOU
MISTER MEMBERS. I MOVING ON TO.
FILE ITEMS. AB TWO BY SOMEONE
NUMBER FONG WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY. I COULD HAVE IMAGINED
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS BILL
REQUIRES ALL PROPOSED
REGULATIONS WOULD COST IMPACTS
A FIFTY MILLION OR MORE.
REVIEWED BY THE LEGISLATURE AND
AB TWO ALSO REQUIRES AGENCIES
TO REVIEW AN AMENDED
DUPLICATIVE OR OUTDATED
REGULATIONS. BECAUSE
REGULATIONS COULD ALTER THE
DAILY LIVES OF CALIFORNIANS AND
SHOULD BE REVIEWED BY THE
LEGISLATURE TO MAKE SURE THEY
ARE CONSISTENT WITH THE INTENT
AND THE POLICIES WE PASS OUT OF
THIS BUILDING. WHAT I PROPOSE A
BETTER PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE
LEGISLATURE AND EXECUTIVE
AGENCIES TO PROMOTE REGULATIONS
THAT ARE EFFICIENT CONSISTENT
REFLECTIVE OF TODAY'S
RECOVERING ECONOMY. ESTATE
AGENCIES PROMULGATE MORE AND
MORE REGULATIONS EVERY YEAR TO
AND TO IMPLEMENT STATE POLICIES
THE LEGISLATURE MUST HAVE A
ROLE IN ENSURING EXTREME HIGH
COST REGULATIONS. ARE REVIEWED
BEFORE THEY GO INTO EFFECT IN
ORDER TO MAKE SURE PROPOSED
MAJOR REGULATIONS ARE
CONSISTENT WITH THE INTENT OF
THE LEGISLATURE. I AM JOINED
TODAY BY SCOTT KAUFMAN WITH THE
HOWARD JARVIS TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION SPEAKING IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU WITH A NUMBER OF.
THANK YOU. AT MY IF YOU'LL
PLEASE US WITH MISTER KAUFMAN.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO AND THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH
YOU TODAY. AB TWO WOULD PROVIDE
ALL CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS AND
BUSINESSES RELIEF FROM
BURDENSOME BURDENSOME
BURDENSOME REGULATIONS A COVERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC IN SUBSEQUENT
GOVERNMENT IMPOSED LOCKDOWN TO
PUT A TREMENDOUS STRAIN ON
CALIFORNIA'S BUSINESS COMMUNITY
LEFT MILLION UNEMPLOYED WITH
MANY BUSINESSES STRUGGLING TO
REMAIN OPEN STATE AGENCIES
SHOULD TAKE A CONCERTED ACTION
REDUCE UNNECESSARY REGULATORY
BARRIERS THAT PUT BUSINESSES.
AT GREATER RISK OF CLOSURES AND
STIFLE OUR ECONOMY AB TWO
PROPOSED A GREATER ROLE FOR
STATE AGENCIES AND DEFINE
REVIEWING AND CORRECTING. THE
REGULATION PAPER THEY PROMISE
PRAMILA GATE- THIS WOULD ENSURE
REGULATIONS ARE UP TO DATE
INFORMATION AN ACTOR TO
BUSINESSES ACROSS THE STATE CAN
OPERATE SAFELY WELL GETTING
CALIFORNIANS BACK TO WORK
SPECIFICALLY AB TWO WOULD
REQUIRE AGENCIES TO REVIEW
REGULATIONS IDENTIFY ANY THAT
ARE DUPLICATIVE OVERLAPPING
INCONSISTENT OR OUT OF DATE.
AND ADOPT AMEND OR REPEAL
REGULATIONS TO RECONCILE ANY ON
IDENTIFIED ANY IDENTIFIED
INDIVIDUALS IN THESE AGENCIES
WAS ALSO HOLD A HEARING TO
RECEIVE PUBLIC COMMENT ON THE
PROPOSED CHANGES AND REPORT TO
THE LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR ON
THEIR COMPLIANCE AB TO PROMOTE
EFFECTIVE TRANSPARENT
GOVERNMENT GOVERNANCE WHILE
SUPPORTING THE LIVELIHOOD OF
ALL CALIFORNIANS. WE ASK THAT
YOU SUPPORT IT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER HAVE. AT MODERATOR
IF YOU COULD NOT PLEASE OF UP
THE LINE FOR. AT AND ADDITIONAL
SET. OR UP TEST. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF A
TWO. YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN THE-
ONE OF THEM THEIR OFFER AND
SUPPORT OR ON. OF AID. IT AND
WE'LL GO TO LINE UP A TWO.
TWENTY EXCUSE ME WHAT A LOT OF
TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THE BILL. THANK YOU. I HAVE ONE
MOMENT WE HAVE TWO MORE IN Q. I
LOOK AT THEIR LINE NUMBER. AND
AGAIN WE'RE ON SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF A. B. TO. ROBOTO
LINE. TWENTY EIGHT NINETY ONE.
HI HE GOT VERY. YES WE CAN'T.
YEAH HI I JUST WANT TO CALL-
THEN REPORT AB FORTY SIXTY THE
CALIFORNIA DEPORTES HERNIA
COULD RETIREMENT AT THANK OUR
WE COULD NOT WE WILL A NOTE WE
WILL MAY A NOTE YOUR SOME FOR
THAT- WE ARE ON AB TWO THAT WE
WILL MAKE A NOTE THAT SAYS THAT
YOU ARE SUPPORTIVE OF AB FOUR.
SIXTEEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WHEN WILL GO TO LINE TWENTY IS
SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
FLANK THE CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION- WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE AB TWO IT'S UNNECESSARY
AND COSTLY. UNDER EXISTING LAW
THE OFFICE ADMINISTRATIVE LAW
REVIEWS PROPOSED REGULATION TO
DETERMINE WHETHER THEY MEET THE
STANDARDS SET FORTH IN THE
MINISTER IN A PARTICULAR ACT
ALSO KNOWN AS THE EIGHTY EIGHT-
OF EIGHTY EIGHT REQUIRED THAT
ALL REGULATIONS THE BIG
STANDARDS NOT INCLUDES NON
DUPLICATION. AS A RESULT
EXISTING LAW ALREADY PROVIDES
FOR PROCESS TO ENSURE THAT
PROPOSED REGULATIONS ARE NOT
DUPLICATIVE. OVERLAPPING OR
ANYTHING. EXISTING LAW ALL
PROVIDE THAT ANY INTERESTED
PERSON MAKE THE CASE A STATE
AGENCY TO REQUEST THAT THE
OPTION AMENDMENT OR REPEAL A
REGULATION. THIS WILL INCLUDE
ANY REGULATIONS THAT THE
PETITIONER BELIEVES ARE
DUPLICATIVE OVERLAPPING EGGMAN
INCONSISTENT OR OUT OF DATE. I
WOULD ADD THAT THE UNDERLYING
PAYMENT. YOU WOULD APPEAR TO BE
THAT REGULATIONS ARE BAD.
ASSEMBLY ABOUT THE REGULATIONS
ARE PROTECTION WHICH SAFEGUARDS
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
WORKERS FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA DEPENDS ON THE
PROTECTIONS LIKE REGULATIONS TO
ENSURE THEY HAVE STATE
WORKPLACES ARE PAID AND TREATED
FAIRLY ACTIVE TO CLEAN AIR AND
WATER AND ARE PROTECTED FROM
SERIOUS HARM BY INCOMPETENT OR
NEGLIGENT PRACTITIONERS. THESE
PROTECTION HELP KEEP OUR ROADS
SAFE OUR CROPS THREE FROM
PASSED IN OUR CHILDREN
PROTECTED FROM TOXIC CHEMICALS.
LAST WEEK UNDER AB TWO STATE
AGENCIES INCLUDING THE
DEPARTMENT OF BUSINESS AND
ORDER THEM GIRLS WILL SPEND
TIME AND RESOURCES. ON A
DUPLICATIVE. TIP BURKE
BUREAUCRATIC PROCESS. INSTEAD
PROTECTING THE HOW AND SAFETY
OF WORKERS FAMILY THANK YOU AND-
AB TWO. THE AGENCY WILL HAVE TO
THEIR- TO PROTECT HOW. HEALTH
AND ON. WHAT THEY DID THEIR
THEM REACH. TOWARD BETTER I'LL
BE DONE YOUR PRODUCT PROCESS WE
BY THE BILL THESE WOULD BE
READING IN A RESPECT EAGER TO
STIR YOU TUBE KNOW ON EIGHTY
TWO TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MODERATOR TO WE HAVE ANY
FURTHER WITNESSES ON ARE THE
TOUGH A MY- WE GOT ONE MORE FOR
NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD. I AM
ACTUALLY WAITING FOR THE NEXT
BILL I GOT ABOUT YOUR CREDIT
pFURTHER SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
IN Q. THANK YOU I DO WE HAVE
ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY AND
EITHER SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
FROM THE REMOTE STATION. SCENE
NINE ANYONE IN THE ROOM WISHING
TO TESTIFY AND EITHER SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION I SEE NONE AT ALL
TURN IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU I WILL
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS MEASURE
FORWARD I ACTUALLY THINK THAT
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT I KNOW
THAT. I THE OPPOSITION. I THINK
THEY SAID THAT IT DIDN'T SEEM
TO BE SOURCING FROM A
PERSPECTIVE. THAT REGULATIONS
ARE BAD AND THE REASON THAT I
SUPPORT THIS BILL IS NOT
BECAUSE I THINK REGULATIONS ARE
BAD I THINK THAT. MANY
REGULATIONS ARE NECESSARY
IMPORTANT FOR ALL THE REASONS
THAT CHINA THAT THE GENTLEMAN
ARTICULATED. HOWEVER I THINK
AFTER YEARS AND YEARS OF
AGENCIES TURNING WE KNOW THAT
WE HAVE CREATED IN SOME CASES
DUPLICATIVE. OR CONTRADICTORY
OR LAB OR INSIDE- BREAK
REGULATIONS IN PROCESS HE SAID
I APPRECIATE HI. YOUR WORK TO
TRY TO MAKE OUR GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES MORE EFFICIENT
EFFECTIVE HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS
TODAY- WITH THAT WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE WELL I JUST WANTED. I
THANK YOU OF THE CHAIR AND THE
STAFF FOR THEIR- THEIR
ASSISTANCE THE YOU'VE BEEN A
LEADER ON OVERSIGHT IN TERMS OF
GETTING EDT UNDER CONTROL WE'VE
HEARD IN HEARINGS BEFORE THE TV
HAS A REVIEW THEIR REGULATIONS
AND THEIR INTERNAL OPERATIONS
FOR OVER EIGHTEEN YEARS. SO AB
TWO AT ITS CORE- IS A GOOD
GOVERNMENT MEASURE TO ENSURE
CALIFORNIANS ARE NOT UNDULY
IMPACTED AND BURDENED BY
CUMBERSOME REGULATIONS. CURRENT
LAW DOES NOT REQUIRE
INDIVIDUATION SEATS REVIEW AND
UPDATE REGULATIONS WHICH CAN
WORSEN ECONOMIC EFFECTS FELT BY
THE COBIT NINETEEN PENDEK HE
SAID AS YOU SAID- MADAM CHAIR
REGULATIONS TO BE ACCURATE AND
CONSISTENT. THE BUSINESSES CAN
ACROSS THE STATE CAN OPERATE
SAFELY OF GETTING CALIFORNIA'S
BACK TO WORK SO AND OUR
COLLECTIVE PURSUIT OF MORE
EFFECTIVE GOVERNMENT I RESPECT
THE ASPEN ABOUT. THANK YOU ONLY
HAVE A MOTION BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LACKEY AND A SECOND DEADLY BY
SOMEONE EVER BURKE. IT WAS
BROKEN AND MEDINA THAT RICO
OKAY. SO WITH THAT SECRETARY IF
YOU CAN PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION FOR A B. TWO IS TO
PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
PETRIE-NORRIS HI PETRIE-NORRIS
HI PATTERSON. BURKE BURKE I
GRADE LACKEY MEDINA MEDINA HI
RODRIGUEZ. OKAY THREE OH THAT
BILLS ON CALL THANK YOU HAVE
ALLOW OTHER MEMBERS TO ADD ON
WHEN THEY TRAIN US. MAYBE ON TO
FILE ITEMS SIX AB FOUR SIXTEEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MANAGER MEMBERS.
TROPICAL AND BOREAL FORESTS ARE
AMONG THE MOST CARBON DENSE
FORESTS ON EARTH AND THEY PLAY
A VITAL ROLE IN STORING CARBON
AND PROVIDE HABITAT FOR
COUNTLESS ANIMAL AND PLANT
SPECIES. THE DESTRUCTION AND
DEGRADATION OF THESE PORES DUE
TO INDUSTRIAL SCALE
EXPLOITATION ARE RESPONSIBLE
FOR A SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF
GLOBAL GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
THAT CAUSE CLIMATE CHANGE. AS
WELL AS A WIDE RANGING IMPACTS
ON BIODIVERSITY AND HUMAN
RIGHTS ESPECIALLY WITH REGARDS
PROTECTING INDIGENOUS WAS
STEWARDSHIP AND GOVERNANCE OF
THESE LANDS. AB FOUR SIXTEEN
THE CALIFORNIA DEFORESTATION
FREE PROCUREMENT ACT WOULD
REQUIRE ANY ENTITIES CONTRACT
WITH THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO
CERTIFY THEY'RE NOT
CONTRIBUTING TO TROPICAL OR
BURIAL FOREST LOSS DIRECTLY. OR
THROUGH THEIR SUPPLY CHAINS.
RIVAS VERSION OF THIS BILL IS
PASSED BY THIS COMMITTEE IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN. AB FOUR
SIXTEEN IS MODELED AFTER AN
EXISTING SWEAT FREE CODE OF
CONDUCT FOR STATE CONTRACTS A
PROCUREMENT BAN AGAINST CHILD
LABOR. SO THIS LEGISLATION IS
NOT DISSIMILAR TO PROCUREMENT
POLICIES THE STATE IS
IMPLEMENTED IN PAST YEARS TO
HELP ENSURE THE CONTRACTORS
WERE WORKING WITH ARE NOT
ENGAGING IN HARMFUL PRACTICES.
ALSO IN ORDER TO PROMOTE BEST
PRACTICES SB FOUR SIXTEEN
REQUIRES OUR DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES TO DEVELOP THE
DEFORESTATION FREE CODE OF
CONDUCT TO PROVIDE GUIDANCE TO
CONTRACTORS IN ORDER TO
IDENTIFY FOREST RISK
COMMODITIES IN THEIR SUPPLY
CHAINS. OF THE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD
CALIFORNIA'S PURCHASING POWER
HAS SIGNIFICANT MARKET FORCE
AND THIS BILL EXTENDS OUR
STATE'S ENVIRONMENTAL
LEADERSHIP. THE PROTECTION OF
TROPICAL AND BOREAL FORESTS. BY
ADOPTING THE PROCUREMENT
POLICY. WE ARE ENSURING THAT
THE STATE IS NOT AN INADVERTENT
CONTRIBUTOR TO THE DESTRUCTION
AND DEGRADATION OF TROPICAL AND
BOREAL FORESTS. AND WE'RE
SENDING A CRUCIAL SIGNAL TO
GLOBAL MARKETS BUT ILLEGAL AND
DESTRUCTIVE COMMODITY DRIVEN
DEFORESTATION AND PRIMARY
FOREST DEGRADATION WILL NOT BE
TOLERATED. I STRONGLY BELIEVE
THAT BY ADDRESSING THESE ISSUES
THROUGH SUPPLY CHAIN
ACCOUNTABILITY. WE CAN ACTUALLY
HELP TO DRIVE BETTER PRACTICES
IN THE LONG TERM AS PART OF THE
STATE'S BROAD COMMITMENT TO
LEADERSHIP IN THE FIGHT AGAINST
CLIMATE CHANGE. ALTHOUGH SOME
CONCERNS BEEN RAISED. BY THE
BUILDING INDUSTRY MONICA VERY
CLEAR THIS BILL SPECIFIC TO
ONLY STATE PROCUREMENT. AB FOUR
SIXTEEN ENJOYS BROAD SUPPORT
FROM INDIGENOUS LEADERS
ENVIRONMENTAL POLICY EXPERTS
WILDLIFE ADVOCATES THANK
MURSCHEL BUSINESSES THAT
SUPPORT SUSTAINABLE PRACTICES.
UP WITH ME TODAY ON THE PHONE
IS JEFF CONANT ABOUT THE SENIOR
INTERNATIONAL FORCE PROGRAM
MANAGER WITH FRIENDS OF THE
EARTH U. S. AND JENNIFER SCHEME
THE NATIONAL NATURAL CLIMATE
SOLUTIONS POLICY MANAGEMENT THE
CANADA PROJECT. OF THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA AT
MODERATOR YOU PLEASE CONNECT US
WITH JEFF CONANT. I NEVER OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY THANKS
CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES WE CAN I
PICKED UP OKAY YES OKAY THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE AND THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA MY NAME
IS JEFF CONTENT THAT I
REPRESENT FRIENDS OF THE EARTH
ONE OF THE CO SPONSORS OF AB
FOUR SIXTEEN. EVERY THREE DAYS
THE WORLD LOSES AN AREA OF
FOREST THE SIZE OF LOS ANGELES
WHAT WE LOSE WHEN WE LOSE OUR
FORESTS WE LOSE COUNTLESS
SPECIES TAMARKIN RHINO THE
BORNEAN ORANGUTANS GREAT APES
CARIBOU NUMBERLESS MIGRATORY
BIRDS INDIGENOUS PEOPLE LOSE
THEIR CULTURES LANGUAGES AND
LYFT WEIGHTS AND WE LOSE OUR
LAST BEST CHANCE TO PREVENT AND
MITIGATE RUNAWAY CLIMATE CHAOS
BECAUSE ABOUT A QUARTER OF
GLOBAL GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS. RESULT FROM
DEFORESTATION AND THE
DEGRADATION OF INTACT PRIMARY
FOREST AT THE TWENTY FIFTEEN U.
N. CLIMATE SUMMIT GOVERNMENTS
INDUSTRY AND CIVIL SOCIETY CAME
TOGETHER INSIDE THE NEW YORK
DECLARATION ON FORESTS A
COMMITMENT TO REDUCE GLOBAL
DEFORESTATION BY HALF BY TWENTY
TWENTY AND ENDED BY TWENTY
THIRTY CALIFORNIA AS A CLIMATE
LEADER WAS A SIGNATORY TO THIS
DECLARATION. WHEN THE U. N.
ACEST PROGRESS IN TWENTY TWENTY
WHAT DID IT FIND NOT ONLY HAVE
THE WORLD MISSED THE TWENTY
TWENTY TARGET GLOBAL
DEFORESTATION HAD INCREASED BY
OVER 40% AND WHY IS
DEFORESTATION INCREASING
BECAUSE THERE'S NO ECONOMIC OR
REGULATORY INCENTIVE TO STOP
IT. AB. FOUR SIXTEEN CAN CHANGE
THAT. I WITH EFFORTS UNDERWAY
IN EUROPE COUPLED WITH THE-
BILL IN THE THAT IS NEARLY A
CARBON COPY OF AB FOUR SIXTEEN.
THIS BILL CAN INITIATE A
GROUNDBREAKING APPROACH TO
USING THE POWER OF THE PUBLIC
PURSE TO REFER. TO REVERSE ONE
OF THE MOST DESTRUCTIVE OF
HUMAN AND CORPORATE ACTIVITY. A
DRAFT STUDY REVEALED THAT
ROUGHLY A QUARTER OF
CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC PURCHASING
INFLICTED DEFORESTATION RISK.
THAT SIX HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN PUBLIC PURCHASING
THE COULD BE LEVERAGED TO SAVE
THE WORLD'S FORESTS BUT INSTEAD
IS PAYING FOR THEIR DESTRUCTION.
VIRTUALLY EVERY ENVIRONMENTAL
ORGANIZATION IN THE COUNTRY
WANT TO SEE THIS BILL BECOME
LAW NOT ONLY THAT THE
INVESTMENT COMMUNITY IS BEHIND
THE BILL A COALITION OF
RESPONSIBLE INVESTORS WHO
COLLECTIVELY MANAGE ONE POINT
FIVE. TRILLION DOLLARS IN
ASSETS WILL SHORTLY SUBMIT A
LETTER MAKING THE CASE THAT AB
FOUR SIXTEEN GOOD FOR BUSINESS.
WHY BECAUSE IT WILL CREATE A
LEVEL PLAYING FIELD FOR
INDUSTRY. IT WILL CREATE MUCH
NEEDED TRANSPARENCY IN THE
GLOBAL SUPPLY CHAINS THAT WILL
HOLD CORPORATION TO A STANDARD
OF ENVIRONENTAL STEWARDSHIP OF
THE MARKETPLACE INCREASINGLY
DEMAND. AND THAT WILL HELP
PRESERVE OUR WORLD FOR OUR
CHILDREN AND OUR GRANDCHILDREN.
SO I HEARD YOU RESPECTFULLY TO
PLEASE CAST YOUR VOTE IN FAVOR
OF AB FOUR SIXTEEN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THE THANK YOU MISTER
CONTENT. MODERATOR IF YOU COULD
PLEASE NOW CONNECT US WITH
JENNIFER SKEEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE OPEN. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M JENNIFER SCHEME
WITH THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL ONE OF THE CO
SPONSORS OF AB FOUR SIXTEEN. A
LOT OF THE BOREAL FORESTS WHICH
IS A CRITICAL CLIMATE ALLY THE
CALIFORNIANS AND PEOPLE AROUND
THE WORLD. MADE THE HEADLINES
THE TOPIC OF. THE CLEAR CUT
DURING THE CLINTON BURNING
CARABOTT DELETION AND BATHS
CARBON EMISSION HAVEN'T DRAWN
THE SAME INDIGNATION GENERATED
BY LAW ENFORCING THE GLOBAL
SOUTH. IT BILL IS A STEP
CHANGING THAT MAKING SURE
CALIFORNIA PURCHASES DON'T
COMMITTEE OF THE TROPICS FOR
THIS CRITICAL REGION AND THE
PEOPLE WHO WITH THEIR- EIGHTY
FOUR SIXTEEN IS NOT ABROAD
MORATORIUM PURCHASES FROM THE
BOREAL. PRODUCT CAN AND ARE
BEING FORCED FROM THE BOREAL
FIFTEEN A PLATE. WITH NARROWLY
TAILORED TO ADDRESS ONLY THOSE
OPERATIONS THAT ARE
FUNDAMENTALLY OUT OF SYNC WITH
THE CLIMATE STATE FUTURE AND
INDIGENOUS RIGHT. I CENTER FOR
IN CLOSE ON THE LIMITED IMPACT
FORCE WE HAVE LEFT THAT'S-
BUTTON YOU HAVE TO PROTECT TO
AVOID CLIMATE CATASTROPHE.
OPERATIONS STILL IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE DON'T REQUIRE
CONSENT BEFORE BRINGING THEIR
BULLDOZERS BONTA INDIGENOUS
PLANTS. AND THAT'S NOT
HAPPENING IN THE TROPICS.
HAPPENING IN BORA. CALIFORNIA A
CLIMATE LEADER HAVE TO
INDIVIDUAL AND. DRIVING IS
IMPACT. AB FORTY NOT OUT
STOPPING SOMETHING THAT
CREATING FOR BETTER WITH.
SOMETHING MARKET BY AFTER
BELIEVING INVESTORS ARE ALREADY
CALLING FOR. IF THE CRUCIAL
MEANS OF ENSURING THAT INDUSTRY
CAN CO EXIST ALONGSIDE. A
HEALTHY CLIMATE AND THE WORLD
THAT FULLY RESPECTS INDIGENOUS
RIGHTS. AND THE CALIFORNIA
BUDGET THOSE ARE COMPATIBLE
WITH THE JOB. EQUITABLE
SUSTAINABLE. CLIMATE THE FUTURE.
YEAH TO. THANK I URGE EYES OUT.
YOU I HAVE IF YOU HAD TWO
PRIMARY BUT TEN THANK YOU MESKI
WOULD YOU HAVE TO PRY WITH IN
OPPOSITION MODERATE PLEASE CAN
YOU CONNECT US WITH JEFF
BRADLEY WHO IS JOINING US FROM
THE AMERICAN FOREST AND PAPER
ASSOCIATION. YES THIRTY NINE
ZERO POINT WITH THAT. GOOD
AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO APPEAR BEFORE
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JEFF
BRADLEY MANAGER REPORTS WHAT
PRODUCT POLICY AND I'M SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF THE AMERICANS
WORKING PAPER SUFFICIENT. AB
FOUR SIXTEEN OF TRP THAT
RAISES A NUMBER OF CONCERNS
THAT WE NOTED OUR LETTER BUT
FOR THE SAKE OF FINAL FOCUS ON
FOURTH ASPECTS. A FROM BEGIN
ITS NUMBER SUPPORT FOR
CERTIFICATION CERTIFICATION
PROGRAMS TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
GLOBAL REGIONAL AND SITE
SPECIFIC. FOREST IS. INCLUDING
TO. BIODIVERSITY WHILE. PASTOR
FORETELL AN INTEREST OF
COMMUNITIES AND INTO PEOPLES.
IF PROGRAMS INCLUDE FOR ONE
FIBER SOURCING AND CHAIN OF
CUSTODY. CHEN ACOSTA STANDARD
WHICH APPLIES FIRED THE NINETY
TRACKS FIBER SUPPLY CHAIN ALLOW
FOR YOU SIR CONTENT CLAIM THAT
LABEL PRADA. IT'S PROGRAMS ARE
BACKED BY RIGOROUS THIRD PARTY
AUDITS FROM GERALD TO CARRY
CERTIFIED LABELS. SO IN THE
CONTEXT OF AB FOR SIX. CANADIAN
FOR COMPANIES OPERATE ON PUBLIC
LANDS ON THE PURVIEW OF
PROVINCIAL GOVERNMENTS THE
FORCE MANAGEMENT PLANTS BUILT
ON ONE HUNDRED TWO HUNDRED YOUR
TIME FRAMES. CANADIAN FOREST
HAVE THE MOST THIRD PARTY
CERTIFIED FORCE IN THE WORLD.
CANADIAN STANDARDS ASSOCIATION
FOR STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL AND
THEY WILL FOR SURE NATIONAL.
ALL HAVE CERTIFIED WENT TO
CANADA. CERTIFIED FORCE
MANAGEMENT AND PRODUCTS PROVIDE
EVIDENCE THE CUSTOMERS THAT
WHAT THEY BUY SOURCE FROM
POOREST MANAGED NEED
COMPREHENSIVE ENVIRONMENTAL
SOCIAL ECONOMIC AND ECONOMIC
CENTER. FOR THIS REASON WE
ENCOURAGE AB FOR SIXTEEN TO BE
AMENDED TO REMOVE THE BOREAL
LANGUAGE AND ESTABLISH THE
REQUIREMENTS THE PROCUREMENT
PRACTICES FOR PAPER AND WOOD
PRODUCTS ARE CONSISTENT WITH
THIRD PARTY CHEN CUSTODY
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM. ASSEMBLY
MANAGE FORESTS IN RENEWABLE
FORCE PRODUCTS ARE POWERFUL
TOOLS TO ADDRESS OUR CHANGING
CLIMATE. IN OUR SECTOR
SUSTAINABLE FORESTRY PRACTICES
ENSURE THAT IN THE US AT LEAST
TWICE AS MANY TREES ARE GROWN
AND HARVESTED. AND FORCE
COVERED LAND IN NORTH AMERICA
STABLE FOR MORE THAN A HUNDRED
YEARS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
CONSIDERATION SUPPORT MATTER
MATTER I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU MR
BRADLEY. A MODERATOR PLEASE CAN
CONNECT US WITH STEVE CRUZ WHO
IS A HE REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION. THE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
INCREASED REPRESENTED
CALIFORNIA W. AND SHE THINKS
THE OFFICIAL- IN THE RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION EIGHTY FOUR SIXTY
ONE I GUESS FIRST OF ALL ONE OF
EXPECTED HE HEARD. YEP WE GOT.
RIGHT THANK YOU AS STATED AB
FOUR SIXTEEN REQUIRES A
CONTRACTOR OR SUBCONTRACTOR
CONTRACTED THE PDC TO CERTIFY
THE WOULD OF COURSE RISK MONEY.
DOING SO THANK YOU FOR SIXTY
MINUTES NORTH THE HIGH
STANDARDS THAT ALREADY EXIST-
FOR NORTH AMERICAN DATA BEFORE
SHE PRACTICES TRANSPORTATION.
BACK YEAH A HAS BEEN A STRONG
LEADER IN GREEN BUILDING CODE
PROCESS AND SUPPORTS ASSEMBLY
MANAGE FORESTED WE DO BEFORE.
IF ENACTED EIGHTY FOUR SO WILL
IN. INCREASE PUBLIC EVEN
HOMEPAGE. ACT BECAUSE OF COLD
THE IMPACT IN DEMAND NUMBER
ALREADY. MORE THAN 2100% AND
THIS IS JUST CLASSICAL. NOT SO
WITH THE CURRENT SHALL TIPS
QUARTER AVAILABLE UNDER AT A
TIME WHEN WHICH TO GET THE- FOR
AFFORDABLE. FIFTY CONNECTICUT
AREA INCREASED HOSTAGE. PUT
THAT IN PERSPECTIVE. THE HIGH
COST OF CONSTRUCTING OF THE
MAJOR CALIFORNIA A NET HOUSING
BACKLOG OF MAYBE MILLION HOMES.
FOR EVERY THOUSAND DOLLARS THAT
INCREASE THE PRICE OF THE HOME
THE PRICE ANOTHER TWELVE
THOUSAND HOUSEHOLDS. OUT SO
AGAIN. WOULD BE PRESENTS CBA
MUCH RESPECTED OPPOSE EIGHTY
FOUR SIXTY THANK YOU. TWENTY MR
CRUISE UP MODERATE WE ARE NOT
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES FOR ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT FOR
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY. THANK YOU
REPORTER OPPOSITION OF AB FOUR
SIXTEEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. FOR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE AT TWENTY EIGHTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE KATHY LANCE
REPRESENTING THE WESTERN WHAT
PRESERVATIVES TO ANY AMERICAN
WOOD. IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL. THANK YOU MEXICO
TOWLINE TWENTY NINETY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
VERY NICE AND THE CONCERN
CALIFORNIA CITIZEN AND VOTER
CONSENT BARBER CALIFORNIA ON
THE OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE IN
FAVOR OF AB PLUS THING THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT TO GO TO
LINE TWENTY FIFTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS DR
COULD STILL BEAT THE WITH OUR
HONOR AND WE SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU NEXT TO GO TO LINE
TWENTY NINETY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THEY WERE MARROW WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT ABOUT THE LINE
OF TWENTY ONE OH ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON JAMES
GALLAGHER WITH ENVIRONMENTAL
DEFENSE FUND IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE OF THE TWENTY ONE HUNDRED
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. DIANA WHY
NINE BACK CHAIR OF SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY CLIMATE REALITY CALLING
IN TO EXPRESS MY FULL SUPPORT
AB FOUR SIXTEEN. THANK YOU NEXT
ABOUT THE LINE TWENTY ONE OLD
TO. YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BY THE
JURY- FROM THE GENERAL HEALTH
I'M CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU WE'LL GO TO LINE OF
TWENTY EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI THIS IS JIM
LINDBERG ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION THAT CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
OVER A LINE OF- TWENTY FORTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THINK
ABOUT HIM CHAIR NUMBERS NIKITA
KARATE WITH ENERGY FEEDBACK
AFTER REGISTER STRONG SUPPORT
FOR EIGHTY FOUR SIXTEEN ON
BEHALF OF THE FOLLOWING
ORGANIZATIONS OCEANIC
PRESERVATION SOCIETY FAVOR
SHORT NATIONAL STEWARDSHIP
ACTION COUNCIL CALIFORNIANS
AGAINST WASTE IN THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT ABOUT A LINE OF TWENTY
FIFTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO THIS IS AN EXECUTIVE
SOCIAL COMPASSION IN
LEGISLATION REGISTERING SUPPORT
FOR CO SPONSORS PIECE FOR
ANIMALS AND SUPPORTERS OF LOS
ANGELES STANDS FOR THE
PROTECTION OF ANIMALS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MEXICO TO LINE OF
TWENTY SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NINE TWENTY SIXTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO THIS
IS SORRY THIS IS WALTER STOVER
WITH THE COALITION OF THE ON
HOUSING UNBANKED WE ARE CALLING
IN WITH OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
AS IT WILL CREATE A
DISPROPORTIONATE AND NEGATIVE
FINANCIAL IMPACT ON THE MOST AT
RISK POPULATION UP ON HOW YOU
DOING. I'M BANG THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU WILL GO TO LINE OF
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI I'M CHEN MENDOZA
I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
STANDARDIZED- CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF AB OR SIXTEEN THANK.
THANK YOU KNOCKED OVER LINE OF
TWENTY FIFTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BOTH USED FOR US FOREVER IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT OVER
LINE OF TWENTY FORTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS CAITLYN YOU SEE WHAT
THE FOREST PRODUCTS ASSOCIATION
OF CANADA. FOR CALLING TO
OPPOSE THIS BILL UNDOCUMENTED-
WE HAVE CONCERNS WITH THE
DISCRIMINATORY ASPECTS TO
CANADA THANK YOU MA'AM AND JUST
A REMINDER AT FOR ANYONE
DIALING IN. FOR THIS PART WE
ARE ONLY ABLE TO ACCEPT AT NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION THANK
YOU. AMERICA MODERATOR IF YOU
CAN ON THE NEXT LINE. THANK YOU
ABOUT A TWENTY TWENTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS KILEY RIGHT CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA CALLING IN SUPPORT
OF AB FOUR SIXTEEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MEXICO AT THE LINE OF
THE TWENTY FORTY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. BY TWENTY FORTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME
ALLOWING YOU EAT YES MY NAME IS
EVE EVE MODE YOU'RE AND I
REPRESENT THE GOVERNMENT OF
CANADA. CANADA I RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE AB FOUR ONE SIX IN THE
PRINCIPLE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT ABOUT A LINE OF TWENTY
EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS. FINALLY
KEEP WITH THE CENTER FOR
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY. IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT UP
WE'LL GO TO LINE OF TWENTY
NINETY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI THIS IS A PROJECT TO
COMPLEMENT YOUR PARK AND I
WOULD LIKE TO URGE YOU ALL TO-
HE'S VOTE YES ON. EIGHTY FOUR
FOUR SIXTEEN. THANK YOU NEXT
ABOUT A LINE OF TWENTY SIXTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS FIFTEEN WITH ANDRE I'M
A MEMBER OF THAT TEN OF THE IN
EFFECT INTERNATIONAL I DO
OPPOSE THE BILL IN ITS PRESENT
FORM. THANK YOU NEXT OF OUR
<c.magenta>INE OF TWENTY EIGHTY NINE YOUR</c>
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
KHAN FROM MEYER THIRTY FIVE
MENLO PRK WE SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE OF A TWENTY ONE
FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS BRIAN
WONG I RESIDE IN HILLSBORO-
CONCERNS IT'S ANOTHER THIRD.
AND STRONG SUPPORT OF AB FOUR
SIXTEEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MEXICO LINE OF TWENTY ONE
THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MARK. BY TWENTY ONE THIRTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK THE
TRADE YOU IN IRVINE CALIFORNIA
AND WITH THE COALITION FOR
SUSTAINABLE FOOD PRACTICES- I
DONT THE COR EIGHTY FOUR
SIXTEEN AT THE TRIAL OF OUR
PLANET THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT ABOUT A LINE OF TWENTY ONE
NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
MY NAME IS LADEN WITH HOUSE
CALL BROKER REPRESENT MYSELF
I'M IN SUPPORT OF THAT THE
PERSISTENT. THANK YOU NEXT OVER
LINE TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
JONATHAN DOCTOR AND I'M AT THE
OFFICE FIFTY FUTURE AND I'M
INSTRUCTED POLITICO. THANK YOU
MEXICO LINE OF TWENTY ONE
TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS SAMANTHA
AND I'M FROM HUNTINGTON BEACH I
COULD PUT THE SPELL. THANK YOU
NEXT OF A LINE OF TWENTY ONE
EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
JERRY MEMBERS ASSEMBLY MCKAY ON
BEHALF OF L. P. BUILDING
SOLUTIONS IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
MEASURE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MEXICO LINE OF TWENTY ONE
SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THIS IS. CONKLIN ON
BEHALF THE BUILDERS ALIGN
RESPECT NOT THE TO FOR SICK
THANK. THANK YOU NEXT OF A LINE
OF TWENTY FIFTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI THIS IS. JUDY
VANCOUVER SO FOUNDER OF THE
SOCIAL COMPACT AND LEGISLATION
AND WE ARE THE CO SPONSOR THE
BILL AND WOULD LIKE TO THANK
EVERYONE FOR VOTING PART IN THE
PAST SIMPLY USE THAT BALLPARK
TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE OF TWENTY ONE
THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS AND I'M FROM
SACRAMENTO AND I'M CALLING A
BOLD AT. EIGHTY THIRTEEN
SIXTEEN. OKAY AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER US SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION INTO AT THE TIME.
THANK YOU BYE TRAITOR IS THERE
ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY FROM
THE REMOTE. VIDEO TESTAMENT
TESTIFYING ROOM SCENE THERE
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION SEEN NINE WILL TURN
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. I DO
HAVE A QUESTION I'M- FOR THE
AUTHOR CAN YOU PLEASE JUST
ADDRESS AT THE IN THE
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY THEY I
NOTED THAT THE PROPOSAL AS
DRAFTED I THINK THE PHRASE WAS
IGNORES HIGH STANDARDS THAT
ALREADY EXIST AND- REFERENCED ACOUPLE OF EXISTING
CERTIFICATION PROGRAMS THAT
ADDRESS THE NUMBER OF THE
OBJECTIVES AND GOALS OF THE
BELLS CAN YOU. SPEAK TO THAT
CONCERN AND HELP US UNDERSTAND
WHERE THE GAPS ARE WHAT'S
MISSING AND HOW DOES YOUR BILL
ADDRESSES I THINK BOTH ADDRESS
THOSE GAPS BUT ALSO WORK IN
CONCERT WITH ODD THERE'S
EXISTING FOR MARK'S CHURCH GOT
THAT THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR YOU
KNOW THIS THIS BILL DOES NOT IS
NOT AT ALL IN CONFLICT WITH-
WITH RESPONSIBLE YOU KNOW
FORESTRY MANAGEMENT IN FACT.
THIS BILL ONLY APPLIES TO
INTACT FORESTS WHAT THAT MEANS
IS FOR EXAMPLE IN CANADA THE
FOR THE MAJORITY OF THE FOREST
IS COMMERCIALLY MANAGED THIS
WOULDN'T APPLY. TO THOSE
PORTIONS OF THE FOREST IS
INTACT FORESTS WAS THE FOURTH
IT HAS NOT EVER BEEN DEVELOPED
OR LOG OR IN OTHER WAYS
COMMERCIALLY USED IN SELF I
COMMEND- CANADA THAN AND
COMPANIES THAT ARE COMMERCIALLY
MANAGING FORESTS IN A WAY
THAT'S RESPONSIBLE AND- AND
CERTIFICATION PROGRAMS WHAT
HAVE YOU THAT SUBSTANTIATE
THAT. THAT'S FANTASTIC AND SO
THIS BILL DOESN'T IMPACT THE
WORK THAT'S BEING DONE THERE IN
FACT CANNOT BE CELEBRATE
RESPONSIBLE UP VOTE FOR THE
FORESTRY MANAGEMENT THIS BILL
IS MOST PACIFIC LEE- JUST
TARGETING INTACT FORESTS WHICH
IS THE ONE THAT THE SUN. OF
FORESTS AND ALSO REALLY MOSTLY
CONCERNED ABOUT ESPECIALLY YOU
LOOK AT THE TROPICAL FOREST IN
THE DEGREE OF DEGRADATION
THAT'S BEEN OCCURRING I DO
THINK THAT SOME OF THE SOME
COUNTRIES AROUND THE WORLD BOTH
IN TROPICAL AS WELL AS IN
BOREAL ENVIRONMENTS I HAVE
STARTED TO PICK UP THE PACE IN
TERMS OF RESPONSIBLE
MANAGEMENT. AND SO THE SIGNAL
IS THAT AND REALLY. PREVENTS
WHAT IT REALLY FOCUSES AT IT
THIS DANA CALIFORNIA. IS
PROCURE COME. WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE WE'RE NOT COULD YOU TO ANY
OF THE ENTIRE FOR A- DEBRA.
THANKS FOR CLARIFYING NOT TO
SEE NO FURTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF A MADAM CHAIR OF THE
THINK THAT QUESTION WAS A GOOD
ONE TO HELP PUBLIC LIMITED TO
SUMMARIZE WHAT WE'RE REALLY
FOCUSING ON HERE AND I WILL SAY
THAT THE ONE THING I'LL SAY IS
THAT YOU KNOW I ACTUALLY HAD A
CONVERSATION EARLIER TODAY ITH
THE- CONSUL GENERAL'S OUR CAR
OF THE CANADIAN CONSUL GENERAL
AND- AS THE ONLY CANADIAN BORN
MEMBER OF THE LEGISLATURE- YOU
KNOW. I'M GONNA CONTINUE TO
WORK TO MAKE SURE THAT- YOU
KNOW WE RESOLVE AS MANY
CONCERNS THAT THE CANADIAN
GOVERNMENT HAVE- CONVERSATIONS
ARE ONGOING AND- I HAVE A GOOD
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
GOVERNMENT AND HOPEFULLY WE CAN
FIND A PATH FORWARD. BUT
ULTIMATELY THIS IS ABOUT-
PRESERVING PROTECTING FORESTS
THAT HAVE AN IMPACT ON EACH
EVERY ONE OF US AND I THINK-
AFFECTING THE SUPPLY CHAIN IS
ONE OF THE MOST POWERFUL THINGS
THAT WE- THOUGHT WE CAN DO THIS
THING IT IS WHAT WE'VE DONE IN
OTHER INDUSTRIES AS WELL AND I
THINK WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY.
TO TRULY LEAD LEADER AND WITH.
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU AND I WE'VE
GOT ENOUGH OF COMMITTING. WHO
ARE NOW. PRESENT SO THAT WE MAY
NEED TO WAIT FOR A FEW MARK.
BUT LIST WE HAVE IS THAT WE DO
NOT HAVE A MOTION NORTH SECOND
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FIRST AND A
SECOND ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA.
AND AT. DO SO WITH THAT FROM
HOME SECRETARY WE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS PETRIE-NORRIS
HI PETRIE-NORRIS HI PATTERSON.
BURKE BURKE HI GREAT BLACKIE
MEDINA MEDINA HI RODRIGUEZ.
THANK YOU I WILL PUT THAT PHONE
CALL AND THAT OTHER MEMBERS I
DON THINK YOU'RE SOMEONE NUMBER.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM SEVEN AB
FIVE EIGHTY ONE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
OR WHEN. WHENEVER YOU ARE READY.
HERE WE ARE WELL THANK TO-
MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBER AND COMMITTEE MEMBER.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT TO AB FIVE
EIGHTY ONE WHICH WILL REQUIRE
ALL STATE AGENCIES TO APPLY NEW
FEDERAL STANDARDS ON
COORDINATED VULNERABILITY
DISCLOSURE PROGRAMS LAST FALL
CONGRESS PASSED ALONG TO THE-
THE BILL INTO LAW THE INTERNET
OF THINGS CYBERSECURITY
IMPROVEMENT ACT WHICH DIRECTED
NOUS TO CREATE STANDARDS AMONG
OTHERS AND PUBLISH THEM BY JUNE
SECOND OF THIS YEAR ACCORDED
VULNERABILITY DISCLOSURE
PROGRAM IS THE PROCESS BY WHICH
AN AGENCY CREATES. A WAIT TO
RECEIVE INFORMATION ABOUT
POTENTIAL SECURITY
VULNERABILITY FROM OUTSIDE
SOURCES USUALLY SECURITY
RESEARCHERS THAT ARE REFERRED
TO. AS WHITE HEIGHT WHITE HAT.
OF HACKERS THE PROGRAM ALSO
OUTLINES HOW TO SHARE WITHIN AN
AGENCY AND WITH PARTNERS THE
STEPS NEEDED TO RESOLVE THE
VULNERABILITY BY APPLYING THOSE
UPDATES STANDARDS. AND USING
EVERY SOURCE OF THREAT
INFORMATION AT OUR DISPOSAL
STATE SYSTEMS AND DATA WILL BE
MORE SECURE. WILL BE MORE
RELIABLE AND WILL PROVIDE
CALIFORNIANS WITH THE SERVICES
AND PRIVACY THEY EXPECT AND
DESERVE. Q. AND I HAVE NO
PRIMARY WITNESS THE BILL. ALL
RIGHT AT OKAY SO YOU HAVE NO AT.
WITNESSES A PRIVATE WE DON'T
HAVE A PRIMARY WITNESS OR IN
OPPOSITION OR IN SUPPORT THE
MODERATOR IF YOU CAN PLEASE
OPEN UP THE MAIN LINE FOR ANY.
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY. THANK YOU.
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF AB FIFTY ONE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO NOW.
ONE AND THEN. ZERO AND MODERATE
I'M SORRY THIS THAT MIGHT
COMMITTEE SECRETARY JUST
CLARIFIED BUT ME THAT WE DO
HAVE THAT THE GENTLEMAN MICHAEL
MARTINEZ JOINING US FROM THE
DETERMINE I'M SURE OF INSURANCE
IF WE CAN OPEN HIS LINE AND HE
HAD HE WAS HERE TO SPEAK IN.
OPPOSITION MICHAEL YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR AND WE
ARE ACTUALLY JUST HAVE CONCERNS
WE ARE NOT A TECHNICALLY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE MEASURE BUT
I'LL BE VERY BRIEF AND QUICK.
MICHAEL MARTINEZ SENIOR DEPUTY
COMMISSIONER AND LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE HERE ON
BEHALF OF INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER RICARDO LARA WE DO
HAVE A GENERAL CONCERNS ABOUT
EIGHTY FIVE EIGHT ONE REALLY
JUST AROUND MEETING THE
PRESCRIBED COMPLIANCE TIMELINE
SET FORTH IN THIS MEASURE. AS
THE AUTHOR HAD STATED THAT
THERE IS A JUNE SECOND TWENTY
TWENTY ONE DATE OF FOR THE
GUIDELINES TO BE FINALIZED AND
PUBLISHED WHICH IS EXACTLY FIVE
WEEKS FROM TODAY BUT JUST KNOW
THAT THE GUIDELINES HAVE YET TO
BE PUBLISHED IN DRAFT FORM FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT. TO THERE IS A
PUBLIC COMMENT PERIOD THE INPUT
RECEIVED A COULD BE REVISED.
AND THEN FINALLY- PUBLISHED AND
SO WE WERE JUST CONCERNED
ABOUT. THE JULY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY TO TURN AROUND TIME
BECAUSE IT COULD BE ULTIMATELY
TOO SHORT TO COMPLY WITH- WE
THE REST OF THE BILLS AGAIN NO
NO CONCERNS AT ALL IT'S REALLY
ABOUT. BEING ABLE TO MEET THAT-
THAT THAT THAT CERTAIN
COMPLIANCE STATE. OR OTHERWISE
UNKNOWN UNRELEASED FEDERAL
GUIDELINES SO JUST THANK YOU
FOR LISTENING TO OUR CONCERNS
WE LOOK FORWARD TO. CONTINUING
CONVERSATIONS WHAT THE AUTHOR
AND HER STAFF OF THIS MEASURE
CONTINUES TO MOVE FORWARD IN
THE PROCESS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER MARTINEZ I AND
MODERATOR IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN EITHER
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. YES IT
WILL GO TO LIKE TWENTY SEVENTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I TWENTY
SEVENTY FOUR CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES WE CAN. HI THE FIRST
ANTHONY WU FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUMPER. AT DOJ HAS NO
OFFICIAL POSITION AT THE TIME
BUT WE SHARED SOME OF THE SAME
CONCERNS. AT THE OTHER
CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICES THAT
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
OTHER TOPIC TO ADDRESS THEM
THANK YOU THANK YOU. WHY I
DON'T NEED A NUMBER. THANK YOU
NOW WE'LL GO TO LINE OF TWENTY
NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ONE TWENTY NINETY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS WHAT.
LOPES ONE MOMENT PLEASE. OKAY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHAT WILL I
STILL HAVE TO RE QUEUE UP
TWENTY NINETY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. OKAY PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS
VENTURA ON BEHALF OF STATE
CONTROLLER BETTY YEE ALIGNING
OUR CONCERNS WITH THAT PICTURE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND NEXT
TO GO TO LINE OF TWENTY ONE
FORTY FOUR. YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON SHOW COMMITTEE
MEMBERS BUT JOHNSON ABOUT THE
STATE SUGAR JOHN AMMAR HERE TO
NEUTRAL POSITION- WE HAVE THE
SAME CONCERNS IN OTHER CLASSES
OFFICERS. AND LOOK FORWARD TO
GETTING GAUGE AND WORKING ON
HIS OFFICE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER
SUPPORTER OPPOSITION QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU IS THERE
ANYONE WISHING TO SPEAK AND
EITHER SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION IN
THAT VIDEO. REMOTE VIDEO
STATION THING NINE IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM
WISHING TO SPEAK AND SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION SEEN NONE. I TURN IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
IRWIN LOVE ME LIKE TO CLOSE
TOGETHER FIVE EIGHT FIVE
CERTAINLY WHAT WE'VE HEARD A
NUMBER OF COMMENTS ABOUT THAT-
JUNE SECOND DATE WITH THERE'S
NO EXPECTATION THAT THE
STANDARDS ON JUNE SECOND ARE
GOING TO BE A CONTROVERSY ALL
IN THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS
ALREADY- REQUIRED FEDERAL
AGENCIES TO IMPLEMENT THEM BUT
WE ARE ALSO GOING BY THE
LEGISLATIVE CALENDAR SO WE
STILL ARE GOING OVER TO THE
SENATE AND- PROBABLY THE BILL
WILL BE. HOPEFULLY SIGNED IN-
SEPTEMBER AND THAT WILL GIVE
THE AGENCIES PLENTY OF TIME TO
REVIEW THE STANDARDS AND WORK
WITH OUR OFFICE. UP TO EXPECT
WAY AFTER OF. THANK YOU I THINK
TO WIN. WE HAVE A MOTION ONE
WASH FROM THE NOW WE NEED
AFFECT WE HAVE A FROM A- EIGHT
WILL SAY TO THE MOTION. I
SECOND A SECOND FROM
PETRIE-NORRIS AND WITH THAT.
MADAM SECRETARY WOULD YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION FOR AB FIVE EIGHTY ONE
IS TO PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
PETRIE-NORRIS HI PETRIE-NORRIS
HI PATTERSON. BURKE BURKE I.
GREAT. LACKEY MEDINA MEDINA I
RODRIGUEZ. THREE I WILL PUT
THAT FELL ON CALL AND WAIT FOR
OTHER MEMBERS TO ADD ON AND
THEN I BELIEVE YOU'RE UP NEXT
WITH AB EIGHT OR NINE YES I AM-
THANK YOU. VERY MUCH. SIDE IT
DOESN'T BUT WHEN I ARRIVED HERE
IN THE LEGISLATURE OF FOLLOWING
A SKATING AUDITOR'S REPORT
ABOUT THE- CONDITION OF CYBER
SECURITY AND ALL OUR EXECUTIVE
STATE DEPARTMENTS I RAN A BILL
TO REQUIRE EVERY DEPARTMENT TO
DO A SECURITY ASSESSMENTS. AND
SENSE. WE HAVE- OF THAT IN IN
THOSE OF- IN THE FOLLOWING
YEARS SO WE HAD AMY TONG WHO
REALLY DID A GOOD JOB OF
IMPLEMENTING IT THE STANDARDS
MAKING SURE THAT DEPARTMENTS
DID ASSESSMENTS AND AUDITS AND
FIGURED OUT WHAT THEY'RE OF
MATURITY WISE AND THE STANCE
RIGHT NOW OF CYBER SECURITY IN
THE STATE DEPARTMENT IS
EXTREMELY HIGH THEY'VE WORKED
VERY HARD TO GET AT THAT POINT
BASICALLY ASSERT SECURITY
ASSESSMENT IS PENETRATION
TESTING. AND THEN IDENTIFYING
OF VULNERABILITIES AND COMING
UP WITH A REPORT ON HOW YOU ARE
GOING TO ADDRESS THOSE
VULNERABILITIES SO FOR THE LAST
FOUR YEARS I HAVE BEEN WORKING
TO A REQUIRED A CONSTITUTIONAL
OFFICER IS AN INDEPENDENT
BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS TO
BASICALLY DO THE SAME THING AND
FOR FOUR YEARS WE HAVE- HAD
STUMBLING BLOCK BLOCKS ALONG
THE WAY FOR VARIOUS REASONS. I
WILL REMIND THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THAT WE DO HAVE
OVERSIGHT RESPONSIBILITIES OF
THE CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICERS AND
THE INDEPENDENT BOARDS AND
COMMISSIONS ALSO WELL LAST YEAR
WE HAD THE CITY AUDITOR WITH
ANOTHER SCATHING REPORT ON AND
THE- THE CONSTITUTIONAL
OFFICERS AND REALLY THAT THE
REQUIRED THE OF THE SUGGESTIONS
OF THE STATE AUDITOR WERE.
PRETTY MUCH EXACTLY THE
SUGGESTIONS OF THE BILL THAT WE
HAVE IN FRONT OF YOU THIS YEAR
SO I WE ARE NOT QUITE THERE OF
WITH THE CONSTITUTIONAL
OFFICERS BUT WE ARE HOPING THAT
THIS IS THE YEAR WE CAN
FINALLY. MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN
PROVIDE OVERSIGHT AND MAKE SURE
THAT OUR- CONSTITUTIONAL
OFFICES ARE APPROACHING THE
SAME US CYBER SECURITY STANCE
THAT- THE EXECUTIVE DEPARTMENTS
ARE A. PART OP I HAVE ACHIEVED.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY AND IT WILL
WE'VE GOT. A SAY. OKAY ARE
THERE NOPE I UNDERSTAND THERE
ARE NO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT IS THAT CORRECT THAT IS
OKAY- BUT WE DO HAVE TWO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION THE
SPELL. OUT MODERATOR IF YOU CAN
PLEASE CONNECT US WITH THEN
TRAFALGAR WHO IS JOINING US
FROM THE STATE COMPTROLLER'S
OFFICE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN GOOD.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY UP BY MY
NAME IS BEN TURBO WITH THE
OFFICE OF STATE CONTROLLER
BETTY YEE ALSO I'M JOINED BY
OUR CHIEF INFORMATION SECURITY
OFFICER AND GERMAN I WOULD HAVE
TO CONTROL HE I'M A DIRECTLY
OPPOSE EIGHTY EIGHT OR NINE
MONTHS AMENDED. THE BILL WOULD
REQUIRE CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICES
IS CLOSED ACTIVE INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY VULNERABILITIES ON
AN ANNUAL BASIS THE ASSEMBLY
PRIVACY AND CONSUMER PROTECTION
COMMITTEE IN THE FORM OF
CORRECTION ACTION PLANS.
CORRECTIVE ACTION PLAN CONTAIN
CONFIDENTIAL I. T. BONE ABILITY
INFORMATION SUBJECT TO STRICT
ACCESS CONTROLS WITHIN THE FCO
DEPENDABLE ABILITY INFORMATION
DOES NOT LEAVE THAT FEEL
DISABILITIES DURING THE COURSE
OF NORMAL BUSINESS INCLUDING
DURING I. T. SECURITY AUDITS
AND INSPECTIONS AND THIS. WOULD
BE A SIGNIFICANT SECURITY RASK.
CURRENTLY I FEEL CALLED THAT
PRACTICE WORKED EXTERNAL AUDITS
WHICH IS. TO ENSURING THAT AND-
OF FEELS NETWORK AND JUST. YEAH
WORK COLLAB. WITH A LOT OF WHO.
HERE TO POLISH. FOR HANDLING
DATA PRIOR TO COMMENCING. IF
YOU'LL PROVIDE AUDITORS
NONCONFIDENTIAL. IN ENCRYPTED
FORMAT BEFORE ARRIVING AT FIELD
OFFICES. CONFIDENTIAL
INFORMATION IS SHARED WITH
AUDITORS UPON ARRIVAL AND NEVER
LEAVES ANFIELD CUSTODY. HONORED
CONDUCTOR ON ACTIVITIES ON SITE
IN ONLY WE PUT THEIR WALKING
PAPERS. WORKING PAPERS ALONG
WITH ANY AUDIT EVIDENCE
COLLECTED I RETAIN FOR MUTUALLY
AGREED AMOUNT OF TIME AND
SECURELY DESTROYED THERE AFTER.
THE CONTROLLER PREACHING IN TEN
EIGHTY EIGHT OH NINE AND
SUPPORT INCREASED OVERSIGHT.
HOWEVER AFTER ACTED AB EIGHT OR
NINE LACK NECESSARY BEST
PRACTICES THAT ARE CUSTOMARY
DURING IT SECURITY AUDIT TO
MITIGATE RISK. WE ARE CURRENTLY
REVIEWING THE COMMITTEE THE
MAMMOTH ROAD TODAY AND
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR THAT IS
GOING TO CONTINUE OUR DIALOGUE
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY.
TO FIND A MORE HAPPY ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU MISTER
TRAVAILS AT MADRE IF YOU'D
CONNECT US WITH MICHAEL. WHO IS
TO US FROM THE DEPARTMENT
INSURANCE. THANK YOU YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YES THANK YOU MICHAEL
MARTINEZ HERE ON BEHALF OF
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER RICARDO
LARA AND THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT INSURANCE. JUST WANT
TO STATE THAT I AGREE WITH MANY
OF THE CONCERNS THAT THE
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE STATE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE STATED
ABOUT THIS MEASURE AND WE MUST
REGRETFULLY CONTINUE TO OPPOSE
AB EIGHT ZERO NINE UNLESS
FURTHER AMENDED. COMMISSIONER
LOT APPRECIATES THE AUTHOR'S
INTENT TO INCREASE IT SECURITY
AND OVERSIGHT OF STATE AGENCIES
INCLUDING THOSE OVERSEEN BY THE
STATE'S CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICERS
WE HAD PREVIOUSLY REPORTED
AMENDMENTS TO THE DOCTOR'S
OFFICE IN THIS COMMITTEE TO
HELP ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS AND
OFFER A MORE SECURE METHODS. OF
SHARING IT SECURITY INFORMATION
WHILE HELPING THE AUTHOR
ACHIEVED INTENT WITH THIS BILL
REALLY OUR MAIN CONCERNS REMAIN
FOCUSED ON THE MANDATE IN THE
BILL THAT ARE DEALT CORRECTIVE
ACTION PLANS BEFORE TODAY
MANUALLY. I AM SO. A VIRTUAL
CEREMONY. WE TO VALUE THE COULD
NOT BE HEARD OF. THERE ARE
EIGHT DIFFERENT INTERVENTIONS
AS A MAKES REGIS HAVE ONE LIFE
I GOT IT YOU DON'T GREAT THANK
YOU OKAY SORRY MISTER MARTINEZ
CARRY ON. NO WORRIES OF COURSE.
WE DO THE FAITH OF THIS- TO.
HELP ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS
THROUGH A RECENTLY RECEIVED A
COPY OF THE TWO OF THE
COMMITTEES PROPOSED MARKETS
MOMENTS- WHICH WOULD HAVE THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON PRIVACY
CAN CANCER PROTECTION CONSULT
WITH US. TO DETERMINE THE FORM
AND CONTENT REQUIRED FOR
COMPLIANCE CERTIFICATION
CORRECTIVE ACTION PLANS
ALTHOUGH THIS IS A STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION WE BELIEVE
FURTHER CLARITY IS STILL NEEDED
IN THE BILL ON THE LEVEL OF AN
OF DETAIL REQUIRED IN THESE
PLANS. AS WELL AS YOU BUT
POTENTIALLY PUT A POTENTIAL
DISAGREEMENT COULD STILL OCCUR
BETWEEN CONTENT OF A CORRECTIVE
ACTION PLAN OF THE STATE AGENCY
AND THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE AND
HOW THAT WOULD BE RESULT IN
CLOSING WE APPRECIATE ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE AUTHOR
AND HER STAFF. IN HOPES THAT
OUR CONCERNS TO BE FULLY
ADDRESSED UNTIL SUCH TIME WE
REMAIN OPPOSED TO AB EIGHT
ONLINE UNLESS FURTHER AMENDED
THANK YOU. I THINK YOU MISSED
MARTINEZ. MODERATOR WE'VE NOW
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINE FOR ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WHO WISH
TO SPEAK AND EITHER SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU FOR IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF AB
EIGHT OH NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. ONE OF THEIR-
FOR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. OKAY
AND WE WILL GO TO LINE OF
TWENTY ONE FORTY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON SURE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS BLAKE JOHNSON
ON BACKSTAGE OF YANMAR ENOUGH
IS NOT AMENDED. I'M WE HAVE
COMMITTED THE CONCERNED MADE BY
THE CONTROLS OFF THE DEPARTMENT
INSURANCE AND LOOK FORWARD TO
GET YOU THE GATE THE OFFICE
OFFICE THANK YOU. THANK YOU ONE
AND THEN ZERO IF YOU'RE NOT. OR.
TO AND WE HAVE NO MORE
OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU IS THERE
ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY FROM
THE REMOTE VIDEO STATION C.
NINE THIRTY ONE IN THE HARING
ROOM PUSHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION SCENE NINE
ALTERNATE BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
ALL RIGHT I'M I DO HAVE A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS TO FIRST I
KNOW THAT YOU AND YOUR STAFF
HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH OUR
COMMITTEE TO ADD SOME
CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS TO THE
BALLOT JUST WANNA CONFIRM THAT
YOU'LL BE ACCEPTING. THOSE
AMENDMENTS GREAT AND THEN. I
JUST WANNA PICK UP ON SOME OF
THE POINTS THAT THE OPPOSITION
RAISED- THEY- ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE DISCLOSURE OF.
SENSITIVE VULNERABILITY
INFORMATION- HOW HAVE WE
NAVIGATED. THIS CHALLENGE WHICH
MUST BE THE SAME. CHALLENGE AS-WE'VE IMPLEMENTED THESE
STRENGTHENED CYBERSECURITY
PROTOCOLS ACROSS THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH AGENCIES IF YOU COULD
SPEAK TO THAT AND- OBVIOUSLY
ANY OTHER. POINTS THAT YOU WANT
TO ADDRESS THAT WERE RAISED BY
THE OPPOSITION CERTAINLY SO-
THERE'S A LONG HISTORY WITH
THIS BILL AND INITIALLY WE HAD
ASKED THE CONSTITUTIONAL
OFFICERS IF THEY WOULD BE
WILLING TO REPORT TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY. WHICH
IS WHERE ALL THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH AGENCIES A REPORT TO SO
THE DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY%
FOR THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH IS
REALLY DOING. MOST OF THE
OVERSIGHT. BUT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHAD WHEN I GO A QUARTERLY. TO
A SECURE ROOM AND LOOK AT THE
REPORTS TO SEE HOW THE- HOW THE
VULNERABILITIES ARE IMPROVING
THE NUMBER OF CLICKS ARE
IMPROVING AND- THE DIFFERENT
METHOD METRICS TO SHOW WHAT HOW
MATURE THE- CYBERSECURITY
STANCES OF. THE DIFFERENT
DEPARTMENTS AND WHEN WE ARE
ABLE TO SEE THE CORRECTIVE
ACTION PLANS AND THAT WAY
CORRECTIVE ACTION PLANS ARE. BY
THE WAY THAT THIS IS NOTHING
THAT IS TOP SECRET THIS IS. YOU
DO NOT HAVE GOOD PASSWORD
PROTOCOLS OR YOU ARE NOT DOING
ENOUGH EMPLOYEE TRAINING TO
MAKE SURE PEOPLE DON'T CLICK ON
LINKS HELP. FAIRLY HIGH LEVEL
AND- SO NOT NOT THE TYPE OF
VULNERABILITIES THAT ARE IF
THEY WERE EVEN OUT IN THE
PUBLIC WHICH THEY ABSOLUTELY
WOULDN'T BE THE- ASSEMBLY HAS-
THE COMPLETE ABILITY TO KEEP
EVERYTHING. CONFIDENTIAL AND
YOU KNOW WE ARE PROTECTED BY
CHP THERE ARE LOCKS THEY'RE
LOCKED- HERE AT SAFE HERE THERE
IS THERE ARE PLENTY OF WAYS
THAT. WE WOULD BE ABLE TO HAVE-
THE HEAD OF PRIVACY LOOK AT
THESE CONFIDENTIAL REPORTS. THE
AT THE AMENDMENT THAT THEY
ASKED FOR THAT THEY WERE
COMFORTABLE WITH WAS. FOR THE
HEAD OF PRIVACY TO GO TO EVERY
TO BERMAN SEPARATELY- THERE ARE
TWO TWO A THEM AND THINK THAT
THAT WOULD BE AN INCREDIBLE
BURDEN. SO WE ARE CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH THESE DEPARTMENTS.
AND- TO TRY TO FIND SOMETHING
THAT THEY'RE COMFORTABLE WITH
BUT WE DON'T WANT TO WAIT
ANOTHER YEAR AS I SAID THIS HAS
BEEN A FOUR YEAR EFFORT THAT
THEY HAVE BEEN- RESISTANT OR
CONCERNED ABOUT. AND AT THIS
POINT THE AUDITOR IS HAS HAS
DEFINITELY POINTED OUT THAT
THIS IS A PROBLEM AND WE HAVE
TO COME TO A RESOLUTION SO
WE'VE ACTUALLY BEEN WORKING
VERY COLLABORATIVE A
COLLABORATIVE LEE WITH ALL THE
GROUPS BUT WITH A DIFFERENT
CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICERS
OBVIOUSLY WE WANT TO. WE HAVE
TO GET TO THE POINT WHERE THEY
ALL FEEL COMFORTABLE. THANK YOU
FOR DRESSING NOT THANK YU FOR
YOUR COMMITMENT TO A SEPARATE
SECURITY AND ENSURING PRIVACY-
WITH THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
LIVE A- PERFECTLY AFTER I BROKE
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU OUT WE HAVE
A MOTION FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BURKE AND A SECOND FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA. MADAM
SECRETARY WOULD YOU IT'S AT THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
MADAM SECRETARY PHIL PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. YOU
PETRIE-NORRIS HI THREE NORTH
SIDE PATTERSON. BURKE BURKE HI
GRAPE. LACKING MEDINA MEDINA HI
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I. A FOR-
SAID THAT BILL IS OUT AND LEAVE
IT OPEN FOR OTHERS TO ADD ON
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND-
LET'S SEE. ARE MOVING ON TO AB
AT. NINE TWENTY THREE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FROM US WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY. THE BILL. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AND THANK YOU FOR THAT MOTION
SECOND ON THEIR OWN OR DO
STAVING NINETY THREE AFTER TWO
YEARS OF WORK- WITH THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON NATIVE AMERICAN
AFFAIRS AFTER SEVERAL HEARINGS
THAT IN THAT COMMITTEE THE
FEEDBACK RECEIVED WAS
OVERWHELMING IN THIS INDICATION
OF A BROKEN CONSULTATION SYSTEM
IN NEED OF SIGNIFICANT
IMPROVEMENTS AND THIS BILL IS A
BIG STEP TOWARD SOLVING THOSE
ISSUES BUT ALSO SHOULD BE SEEN
AS A FIRST STEP. MANY OF OUR
EXECUTIVE LEVEL AGENCY STAFF
HAVE TREMENDOUS EXPERIENCE IN
EDUCATION IN THEIR ISSUE AREAS.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY LITTLE TO
NONE IN THE AREA OF TRIBAL
GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS TRIBAL
CULTURE OR GOVERNMENT TO
GOVERNMENT CONSULTATION. THIS
BILL WILL CREATE ADEQUATE
TRAINING FOR OUR STATE AGENCY
STAFF. BUILT UPON THE DIRECT
INPUT OF TRIBAL REPRESENTATIVES
FROM THE CALIFORNIA TRIBES. SO
THAT THEY CAN APPROPRIATELY AND
EFFECTIVELY INTERACT WITH OUR
STATE'S TRIBAL GOVERNMENT. WE
HAVE SEEN THIS ISSUE BECOMES
PARTICULARLY APPARENT IN RECENT
YEARS AS WILDFIRES AND COVERT
NINETEEN HAVE INCREASED THE
NEED FOR FAST AND EFFECTIVE
CONSULTATION BETWEEN TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS AND STATE
GOVERNMENTS UNFORTUNATELY.
COMMUNICATION BREAKDOWNS THAT
HAVE OCCURRED HAVE HAD HUMAN
AND ECONOMIC IMPACTS TO THE
TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. FOR THIS REASON
WE MUST TAKE ACTION TO BOLSTER
OUR STATE GOVERNMENT TO
GOVERNMENT CONSULTATION AT
ADEQUATELY PREPARE OUR AGENCY
THIS BILL HAS A LOT OF SUPPORT
AND IN THE TRIBAL COMMUNITIES
INCLUDING THE MORONGO BAND OF
MISSION INDIANS THE SALMON WELL
BAND OF MISSION INDIANS THE
YUROK TRIBE. JUDGE A DAY HE
BOROUGH NOT AND MANY OTHERS. WE
SEE THIS AS A FIRST STEP IN
MOVING FORWARD JOINING ME TODAY
ARE CAROLINE BEALE HUNTER ON
BEHALF OF THE YOSHI DAY HE WENT
TO NATION AND KATHY CLAMMY OF
THE VERONA BAND OF MISSION
INDIANS. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RAMOS MODERATOR IF YOU
COULD PLEASE CONNECT US WITH
KATHY. IS TWENTY NINTH ON
BEHALF OF BROWN. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO I
AM KATHY CLEANING GENERAL
COUNSEL FOR THE BOROUGH IN THE
BAND OF MISSION INDIANS AND
ENROLLED MEMBER UPSET BLACKFEET
NATION. CALIFORNIA INDIAN
TRIBES HAVE SOVEREIGN AUTHORITY
OVER THEIR MEMBERS IN MY HAND
AND THE UNIQUE RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
TODAY GOVERNMENT CONSULTATION
IS ENCOURAGED UNDER STATE LAW
WELL GOVERNOR NEWSOM REAFFIRMS
THE STATE'S COMMITMENT TO
CONSULTATION IT'S A SUBJECT TO
CHANGE WITH EACH NEW
ADMINISTRATION. THIS BILL
CODIFIES THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH
OF COMMITMENT TO GOVERNMENT A
GOVERNMENT CONSULTATION
ESTABLISHES A PROCESS AND
DEDICATES THE OFFICIALS THAT
HAVE THE ABILITY TO REPRESENTS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WE
APPRECIATE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
PROMISES LEADERSHIP TO CLARIFY
THIS POLICY AND SECURE THIS
COMMITMENT WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR ANY AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER A I THINK IT MIGHT HAVE
THE WRONG AT NAME WRITTEN DOWN
WHO IS YOUR SECOND WITNESS
CAROLINE BILL HUNTER RIGHT I'M
FROM MIGRATED TO HE GREAT I'M
MODERATE IF YOU CAN PLEASE OPEN
UP THE LINE FROM ITS BILL
HUNTER. THANK YOU. NEARLINE
SHOULD BE OPEN. FOUNDED BY
EXECUTIVE ORDER IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN GOVERNORS TO APOLOGIZE
ON BEHALF OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO ALL CALIFORNIA
NATIVE AMERICANS FOR THE
MISTREATMENT OF INDIGENOUS
PEOPLE THROUGHOUT THE STATE'S
HISTORY. NINE YEARS PRIOR IN
TWO THOUSAND TEN PRESIDENT
OBAMA SIGNED A SIMILAR
RESOLUTION. THERE IS VALUE IN
ACKNOWLEDGING THE WRONG DOING
THE PAST THE WORDS FALL SHORT
WHEN THEY ARE NOT FOLLOWED UP
WITH INTENTIONAL ACTION TO
REBUILD RELATIONSHIPS AND AB
NINE TWENTY THREE DOES JUST
THAT AND WILL REQUIRE HEADS OF
STATE AGENCIES TO BE PROPERLY
TRAINED AND GOVERNMENT A
GOVERNMENT CONSULTATION WITH
TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS. CALIFORNIA
HAS MORE TRIBES IN ANY OTHER
STATE AND STATE AGENCIES TO
BENEFIT FROM BASIC CONSTRUCTION
ON TRIBAL SOVEREIGNTY AND
TRIBAL CONSULTATION
REQUIREMENTS. IN THE EXERCISE
OF THE STATE'S RELATIONSHIP
WITH TRIED THEY MUST BE
CONSULTED BEFORE DECISIONS ARE
MADE BECAUSE AS WE ALL KNOW
EVEN THE MOST WELL MEANING
POLICIES CAN CREATE FUTURE
UNFORESEEN IMPACTS. THIS PAST
YEARS WE PAID CRISIS AFTER
CRISIS IT BECAME EVEN MORE
OBVIOUS THE TRIBAL ENGAGEMENT
EARLY ON BENEFITS ALL THE
CALIFORNIA. FIRE SEASON YOU
KNOW TODAY HE ITSELF
POTENTIALLY DANGEROUSLY CLOSE
TO THE L. AND YOU FIRE AND
SUFFERED LOSSES. DUE TO THE
CHAOS OF CRISIS TRIBES HAVE TO
PROACTIVELY SEEK OUT
INFORMATION AND RESOURCES AND
IN MOST CASES HAVE TO FEND FOR
THEMSELVES. THIS WAS AVOIDABLE
WE CAN WORK TOGETHER TO SERVE
OUR COMMUNITIES OF STATE
AGENCIES ARE LED BY PEOPLE WHO
ARE TRAINED ON CONDUCTING
MEANINGFUL TRIBAL CONSULTATION
AND CONSIDER NATIVE AMERICANS
WHEN THEY CREATE POLICIES. WE
THANK ASSEMBLYMAN RONALDFOR
AUTHORING EIGHTY NINE TO THREE
AND ARE PROUD TO SUPPORT THIS
MOVE TOWARDS PROGRESS WE ARE
YOU'RE ABOUT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISSPELL HUNTER MODERATOR
IF YOU COULD NOT PLEASE OPEN UP
THAT LINE FOR ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY AND EITHER SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF AB
NINE TWO THREE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. ONE OF THEM
THEY OFFER SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. WE WILL GO TO LIKE
TWENTY EIGHTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. TOPICS BOBCAT. MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE DERAILMENTS THIS
YEAR BUT AFTER UNITED AUBURN
INDIAN COMMUNITY IN OPPOSITION
OF THE MEASURE- NOT OFFERING
ANY TROUBLE CALIFORNIA STANDING
PORTENTS OF RESPECTFUL AND
EFFECTIVE GOVERNMENT TO
GOVERNMENT CONSULTATION AND THE
PROCESS. BUT WE DO BELIEVE THAT
THIS BILL RISKS BUT
INTENTIONALLY UNDERMINING THAT
PROCESS- UNITED AUBURN IS ALSO
VERY STRONGLY OPPOSED GIVING
ANY AUTHORITY FOR CONSULTATION
IN STATUTE. TO THE GOVERNOR'S-TRAVEL ADVISOR. AND WE HAVE HAD
RECENT AT ABOUT HIGH. THOSE
CONCERNS. I'M ESTATE IN THE
BILL GOVERNOR BROWN'S EXECUTIVE
ORDER ALREADY ESTABLISHED A
TRAVEL ADVISOR TO OVERSEE
IMPLEMENT EFFECTIVE GOVERNMENT
TO GOVERNMENT COOPERATION
BETWEEN THE DEMONSTRATION AND
TRIBES. ON POLICIES THAT AFFECT
THE TROUBLE COMMUNITIES WE
BELIEVE THAT ANY FURTHER STEPS
STORY AUTHORITIES REDUNDANT AND
UNNECESSARY. WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR NO VOTE THANK YOU.
APART THANK YOU NEXT TO VOTE TO
LINE TWENTY EIGHTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. TWENTY EIGHTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
PAMELA LOPEZ WITH KEITH STREET
CONSULTING ON BEHALF OF DRY
CREEK RANCHERIA- ALIGN
OURSELVES WITH THE COMMON PARTY
MADE BY MY COLLEAGUE MISTER
ANTENA AND HAPPY TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU WILL GO TO
LINE TWENTY ONE THIRTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU TO
BETTER ENSURE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CORRECT MOST. OF THE
APP OF THE SAN MANUEL BAND OF
MISSION INDIANS AND HE SENATE
HAS BEEN ISSUED IN THE
ASCENDANCY IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ABOUT A
LINE TWENTY SIXTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. NINE TWENTY SIXTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. DO YOU HAVE
A THOUGHT MUTE. YES THIS IS A
BOOST MARKETS ON BEHALF OF THE
RINCON BADLY BEYOND ALL INDIANS
ARE STORMED OPPOSITION TO A. B.
NINETY THREE. THANK YOU AN
EXTRA LINE OF TWENTY ONE FIFTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MADAM
CHAIR SCOTT GOVERNOR ON BEHALF
OF THE MORONGO BAND OF MISSION
INDIANS IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER
OPPOSITION. OR SUPPORT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
MODERATOR IS THERE ANYONE
WISHING TO TESTIFY FROM THE
REMOTE VIDEO SITES YEAH. I
ANYONE INTHE HEARING ROOM
QUESTION TO TESTIFY IN EITHER
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION SEEN NONE
OF BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. I ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ALMOST IF YOU COULD PLEASE JUST
ADDRESS IT AT THE- WAS THE
CONCERN RAISED. BY A THE
GENTLEMAN WHO SPOKE IN
OPPOSITION THAT SOME OF THE
PROVISIONS. COULD POTENTIALLY
UNDERMINE SOME OF THE THINGS
THE BILLS TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH
I DIDN'T COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND.
WHAT THOSE ISSUES WERE BUT
WOULD YOU BE ABLE TO ACCEPT
PRESS THERE WAS CONCERN HELP US
UNDERSTAND THAT THANK THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND YOU KNOW YOU
SEE WITH THE STRONG SUPPORT
THAT WE HAVE FROM IN THE
COUNTRY THIS IS VERY MUCH
NEEDED AS A CONSULTATION. AND
GOVERNMENT TO GOVERNMENT I
BELIEVE THE- SPEAKER IN
OPPOSITION REALLY DIRECTED HIS
CONCERNS TO AUTHORITY GIVEN TO
THE TRIBAL ADVISOR- FOR THE
GOVERNOR HOWEVER THIS BILL DOES
NOT DO THAT. THIS BILL BUILDS
ON CERTIFICATE PROGRAMS
TRAINING THE ADMINISTRATION ON
THOSE THAT WORK WITH TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES ON LEARNING MORE
ABOUT THE HISTORY OF WHAT-
CALIFORNIA PEOPLE ARE TO MAKE
SURE THEY TRULY UNDERSTAND THAT
PROCESS OF IT. THIS BILL
CONTINUES TO MOVE FORWARD THIS
BILL AND WE HAVE AN OPEN POLICY
THAT THOSE THAT ARE WILLING TO
COME AND WORK WITH US ON SOME
LANGUAGE THAT MIGHT BE AMENABLE
WE'RE ALWAYS OPEN TO THAT-
HOWEVER I THINK THIS BILL
FOCUSES ON. BUILDING ON
GOVERNOR BROWN'S- EXECUTIVE
ORDER AND GOVERNOR NEWSOM'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER TO NOW TRAINED
ADMINISTRATION OF THOSE KEY
EMPLOYEES THAT THEN WOULD THAT
WORK WITH TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS
THAT HAVE EXPERTISE IN THEIR
FIELD AND KNOWLEDGE OF CERTAIN
DEPARTMENTS BUT LACK THE
KNOWLEDGE OF UNDERSTANDING
TRUE. CALIFORNIA INDIAN PEOPLE
AND POLICIES THAT ARE THERE AND
AS A FORMER- CHAIRMAN WE COULD
ATTEST THAT THIS HAS BEEN GOING
ON FOR SO MANY YEARS AND YOU
SEE THE SUPPORT OF TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES COMING FORWARD.
THERE IS A FEW THERE'S- THE ONE
THE SPEAKER THAT TALKED ABOUT
THOSE ISSUES BUT IT DOESN'T
ADDRESS THE ISSUE WE HAVE IN
FRONT OF US AND YOU'VE SEEN THE
DIFFERENT BILLS AND THE TOPICS
THAT WE HAVE ADDRESSED IN THE
LEGISLATURE. THE FOR OVER A
HUNDRED SEVENTY YEARS THESE
TOPICS HAVE GONE ABSENT. JUST
LIKE IN THE ROOM THAT WE'RE IN
TODAY THE SPANISH MISSIONARY
PERIOD WAS JUST DESTRUCTIVE TO
THE CALIFORNIA INDIAN THE
PEOPLE YET WE HAVE A ROOM
DEDICATED TO THE MISSION
SYSTEM. WHEN IS THE ISSUE GONNA
COME FORWARD TO DEDICATE A ROOM
TO THE CALIFORNIA DID PEOPLE.
SO WE CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD
IN THESE AREAS AND AGAIN WE'RE
ALWAYS OPEN TO WORK WITH
ANYBODY THAT WANTS TO WORK WITH
US. TO CREATE LANGUAGE THAT'S
AMENABLE. THANK YOU FOR
SPEAKING TO THAT AT SENIOR. MR
MEDINA THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR-
REPRESENTING- RIVERSIDE SIXTY
FIRST ASSEMBLY DISTRICT AND
ALTHOUGH I DON'T HAVE ANY OF.
RESERVATIONS IN THE CITY OF
RIVERSIDE OR IN THE SIXTY FIRST
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT I AM NEAR
MANY OF THEM INCLUDING SAN
MANUEL- AND I KNOW FIRST HAND-
THE MISUNDERSTANDINGS THAT CAN
OCCUR WHEN- WHETHER IT BE LAW
ENFORCEMENT OR OTHER STATE
AGENCIES INTERACT- WITH THE
WITH THE- RESERVATIONS WITHOUT
THE PROPER. KNOWLEDGE OR- OUR
UNDERSTANDING OF THE TRIBES SO
I IT WILL BE VERY HAPPY TO BE
IN SUPPORT OF US A. B. NINE
TWENTY THREE TODAY AND SEE THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS BILL PASSING
THANK YOU THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CLARK FIRST I WANT TO
SAY I NEVER I'VE SAT IN THIS
ROOM FOR HOURS ON END AND NEVER
REALIZED IT WAS DEDICATED TO
THE MISSIONS WHICH- ONLY GOES
TO YOUR POINT WHICH IT AND I
AND I SAY IT ALL THE TIME WHEN
IT COMES TO AFRICAN AMERICANS
IS THAT. UNLESS YOU EDUCATE
PEOPLE ON OUR PERSPECTIVE AND
YOU ACTUALLY HAVE LIVED IN OUR
PERSPECTIVE PEOPLE ALWAYS WANT
TO COMMENT ON WHAT IT'S LIKE TO
BE BLACK OR UNDER SERVED AND
YOU CAN'T TRULY UNDERSTAND IF
YOU'VE HAD THAT EXPERIENCE AND
PEOPLE CAN UNDERSTAND IT ONCE
THEY HAVE TIME TO SPEND WITH
PEOPLE AND HAVE TO TIME TO
CONSULT WITH PEOPLE ON WHAT THE
EXPERIENCE IS LIKE SO I VERY
MUCH SUPPORT WHAT YOU'RE DOING
I FEEL VERY STUPID THAT I NEVER
NOTICE WHAT THIS. DEDICATED TO
HOWEVER IT JUST BROUGHT IT WAS
SUCH A IT WAS AN OFF HANDED
COMMENT BUT- THE- JUDGE
REMINDED ME HOW IMPORTANT IT
IS. THAT THAT PERSPECTIVE OUR
THEME THROUGH EVERYONE'S EYES
TO THINKING THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THOMAS WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
WITH THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR-
THANK YOU FOR THE COMMENTS THAT
ARE THERE AND UNDERSTANDING.
THE WORK THAT CONTINUES TO BE
DONE IN THE LEGISLATURE AND IN
CLOSING I WOULD BE OPEN TO ADD
ANY OF THOSE THAT WOULD WANT TO
COME ON AS CO AUTHORS ON THIS
BILL. AND I URGE AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RAMAH. CENTER GONNA. RIGHT BUT
I COULD ASK THE AUTHOR TO BE
ADDED TO THIS QUOTE THANK YOU
THINK WE MISSED MEDINA. THANK
YOU THANK MISTER. THANK YOU
WE'VE GOT IT WE'VE GOT A MOTION
FOR MISTER MEDINA AND A SECOND
FOR MR RODRIGUEZ MOTION IS TO
PASSED APPROPRIATIONS MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
YES I'M TO PASS APPROPRIATIONS
PETRIE-NORRIS HI PETRIE-NORRIS
I PATTERSON. BURKE BURKE I
GREAT. LACKEY LACKEY I MEDINA
MEDINA I RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I
FIVE ZERO THAT PHYLLIS OUT AND
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR OTHER
MEMBERS TO ADD ON. MOVING ON
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ALMOST THAT MOVIE NINE TO FILE
ITEM NINE AB SIX SIXTY ONE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BENNETT GOOD TO
SEE YOU WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR OF THE
STATE AGENCY BY RECYCLED
CAMPAIGN- HAS NOT BEEN UPDATED
SINCE TWENTY FOURTEEN. AND
CERTAINLY THE WORLD OF
RECYCLING HAS CHANGED A GREAT
DEAL AND QUITE FRANKLY IS
STRUGGLING- A GREAT DEAL AT
THIS POINT IN TIME. SO THIS
BILL AB SIX SIXTY ONE WOULD
UPDATE THE STATE'S RECYCLE.
CONTENT STANDARDS WHENEVER THE
STATE ENTERS INTO CONTRACTS FOR
GOODS AND SERVICES. AND I JUST
LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT- WE- ARE
USUALLY PRETTY GOOD ABOUT
TRYING TO PUSH FOR THE PRIVATE
INDUSTRY TO DO THAT- THIS IS AN
ATTEMPT TO TRY TO MAKE SURE THE
STATE GOVERNMENT DOES IT SHARE
ALSO. VOWED TO MATCH WITH THE
PRIVATE INDUSTRY SO THE BILL
MAKES THAT NEEDED IMPROVEMENTS
IN THE BUY BACK PROGRAMME. OR
THE STATED SHE BY RECYCLED
CAMPAIGN- IT WILL CLARIFY THAT-
SERVICE CONTRACTS ALSO SHOULD
BE INCLUDED WHERE THE
CONTRACTOR PURCHASES
REPORTABLE. ARE RECYCLED ITEMS
BOB IT IS ONE STEP WE CERTAINLY
HAVE A URGENT CLIMATE CRISIS
OUT THERE AND- MAKING SURE
WE'RE ALL DOING OUR OUR SHARED
TURN TO TRYING TO. IMPROVE OUR
PURCHASE OF RECYCLED PRODUCTS
IT MAKES SENSE THE STATE HAS AN
ENORMOUS PURCHASING POWER AND
CAN HELP PUSH THE INDUSTRY TRIP
FOR MORE RECYCLING- AND JOIN
THE PRIVATE INDUSTRY THAT WE
SEEM TO PUSH REGULARLY TO DO
THIS. OP NOW MATT HAPPY TO HAVE
A HEIDI SANBORN THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE NATIONAL
STEWARDSHIP. ACTION COUNCIL
AND- NICK LAPIS THE- DIRECTOR
OF ADVOCACY FOR CALIFORNIANS
AGAINST WASTE ON THE LINE- TO
BE WITNESSES TODAY. AND I
APPRECIATE THIS OPPORTUNITY
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BENNETT MODERATOR IF YOU CAN
PLEASE CONNECT. US WITH MS
SANBORN. HELLO GARY YES. THANK
YOU KAREN MEMBERS I'M HEIDI
SANBORN REPRESENTING THE
NATIONAL CHURCH OF ACTION
COUNCIL A NONPROFIT THAT
ADVOCATES FOR CIRCULAR ECONOMY.
ARKET AUGMENTED BY PATCHING
TOGETHER IS THAT IT IS THE
CARROT NOT THE STICK TO ACHIEVE
OUR GOAL TO CLOSE THE LOOP. I
WORK IN MATERIALS MANAGEMENT
FOR THIRTY YEARS NOW SURE THE
STATE WIDE COMMISSION ON
RECYCLING MARKETS AND CURBSIDE
RECYCLING AND EVEN PREVIOUSLY
WORKED AT CAL RECYCLE IN THE
MARKET DEVELOPMENT SECTION.
DURING MY TIME IN THIS INDUSTRY
I'VE LEARNED ONE SIMPLE TRUTH
THIS MATERIAL FIVE MARKETS WE
DO NOT HAVE A WEIGHT PROBLEM.
THIS IS WHY THE RECYCLING
COMMISSION ALSO ASKED THE
LEGISLATURE IN A REPORT
SUBMITTED IN DECEMBER TO PASS A
BILL LIKE EIGHTY SIX SIX ONE.
IMPROVE OUR RECYCLING SYSTEM
AND REDUCE COSTS WE MUST STRIVE
MARKETS AND SUPPORT.
REMANUFACTURING IN CALIFORNIA.
THANK RECYCLED AS OF. IT'S
VOTING WITH YOUR DOLLARS. IT'S
A STRONGER SIGNAL WE CAN SEND
THE COMPANIES TO REWARD THEM
FOR USING RECYCLED CONTENT IN
THEIR PRODUCTS. AT THE STATE
LEVEL WE ARE VOTING WITH PUBLIC
MONEY. AND WE SHOULD BE
ALIGNING OUR MONEY WITH OUR
MISSION. OUR STATED MISSION IS
TO ACHIEVE A 75% DIVERSION RATE
BUT WE'RE NOT EVEN CLOSE
CURRENTLY AT 37% CALIFORNIA BY
THE LOT OF STUFF FROM PAPER
PRODUCTS TO ELECTRONICS. IF WE
USE TAXPAYERS MONEY WISELY TO
VOTE WE WILL DRIVE MARKETS.
CALIFORNIA ESTABLISH THE STATE
AGENCY BY RECYCLE CAMPAIGN
THIRTY YEARS AGO BUT IT IS
WILDLY OUTDATED AND NEEDS. AN
UPDATE SO THE BILL WILL DO THAT
BY EXPANDING AND UPDATING THE
LIST OF PRODUCTS COVERED
ENSURING THAT RECYCLE CONTENT
OF PRODUCTS IS UPDATED EVERY
THREE YEARS. AND REQUIRING THE
UPDATED LIST OF PRODUCTS TO BE
ADDED TO THE STATE CONTRACTING
MANUAL AND MORE. YOU CAN CLEAR
I'VE WORKED WITH PAINT
RECYCLERS IN CALIFORNIA. WERE
PROMISED THAT THE STATE WOULD
BUY RECYCLED PAINT. AND THEY
NEVER RECEIVED THE PURCHASES
THAT THEY PREDICT THAT. MY
PARENTS USED TO TELL ME I WON'T
ASK YOU TO DO WHAT I'M NOT
WILLING TO DO MYSELF. ASK THE
CALIFORNIA ADOPT THE SAME
MANTRA. SHOULD NOT ASK OTHERS
TO BUY RECYCLED WHEN WE'RE NOT
WILLING TO DO IT OURSELVES. BUT
IF YOU THE CARROT INSTEAD OF
THE SIX I THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BENEFITS LEADERSHIP AND- YOUR
AYE VOTE ON A. B. SIX SIX ONE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS
SANBORN. MODERATOR IF YOU CAN
PLEASE CONNECT US NOW WITH NICK
LAPIS WHO'S JOINING US FROM
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE.
CAPTION ENSURING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS NECROPOLIS OF
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE- THE
SO CALLED FAB RACK LAW WAS
GROUNDBREAKING WHEN IT WAS
FIRST PASSED IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
NINE. BY IDENTIFYING NUMBER
DIANE EASTON. THE LAW WAS
PASSED AT THE SAME TIME AS
CALIFORNIA'S LANDMARK WHICH
PRODUCTION MANDATE ON LOCAL-GOVERNMENTS. IN ORDER TO HELP
CREATE MARKETS FOR THE NEWLY
RECYCLED MATERIAL- IT'S ALSO
DESIGNED AS MENTIONED IN
ANOTHER BILL A FEW BILLS BACK
TO AVOID DEFORESTATION AND
CONSERVE OTHER RESOURCES- THE
BILL HAS BEEN A MODEL FOR OTHER
STATES. AND HAS BEEN REFERENCED
IN MULTIPLE LOCAL PROCUREMENT
GUIDELINES THAT ARE TIED TO THE
SOUNDTRACK PROGRAM- HOWEVER
OVER THE LAST THIRTY YEARS
SEVERAL DEFICIENCIES IN THE
PROGRAM HAVE COME TO THE
SURFACE. AND THIS BILL UPDATES
FABRIC TO ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES.
A FEW OF THE ISSUES THAT HAVE
COME UP. ONE IS THAT THE LIST
OF PRODUCTS IS OUT OF DATE-
CARPET FOR EXAMPLE WOULD BE
CONTEMPLATED IN THE ORIGINAL
LEGISLATION BUT IT'S AN AREA
WHERE CALIFORNIA RECYCLERS ARE
READY AND WILLING TO STEP UP TO
SUPPLY THE MATERIAL. SOME
PRODUCT CATEGORIES ARE
INCORRECTLY DESCRIBED IN THE
LEGISLATION. ONE EXAMPLE THAT
COMES TO MIND OF COMPOST
COMPOST IS BY DEFINITION A
RECYCLED CONTENT PRODUCT SO
INCLUDING A MINIMUM RECYCLED
CONTENT REQUIREMENT FOR COMPOST
NEVER REALLY MADE SENSE IT IS
1100% RECYCLED CONTENT. HOWEVER
INCREASING THE USE OF RECYCLED
COMPOST AND MULCH HAS BEEN A
PRIORITY FOR A VARIETY OF
REASONS- RANGING FROM S. B.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE TO THE
STATE DIVERSION LAWS. SO THIS
BILL UPDATES THE METRIC TO THE
MORE APPROPRIATE MEASUREMENT OF
RECYCLED CONTENT PRODUCTS USED
AS A PERCENTAGE OF SOIL
AMENDMENTS OR EROSION CONTROL
PRODUCTS. WHERE THE PERCENTAGE
OF COMPOST USED IS THE
APPROPRIATE METRIC. AND FINALLY
THERE'S BEE A LACK OF
ENFORCEMENT- IN THE CURRENT
PROGRAM IT REALLY IS NO PROCESS
IN PLACE TO HAVE A STRONG
FEEDBACK LOOP FOR- AGENCIES
THAT ARE NOT IN COMPLIANCE TO
COME UP. TO THEIR APARTMENTS
AND COME UP AND COMPLIANCE. AND
THIS BILL UPDATE SETTING
CREATES A MECHANISM FOR BOTH
DEPARTMENT GENERAL SERVICES AND
COUNTERCYCLICAL. TO HELP GET
STATE AGENCIES ON THE RIGHT
TRACK. AS HEIDI MENTIONED-
THESE CHANGES OF IDENTIFIED BY
THE STATEWIDE COMMISSION ON
RECYCLING MARKETS AND CURBSIDE
DEVELOPMENT. KERBSIDE RECYCLING
I APOLOGIZE- BECAUSE THEY AE
REALLY LOW HANGING FRUIT FOR
SUPPORTING CALIFORNIA RECYCLING
AND CREATING AND STATE JOBS.
FOR THOSE REASONS WE ARE DRIVE
VOTE AND WANT TO EXPRESS OUR
APPRECIATION TO THE AUTHOR FOR
CARRYING THIS BILL. THANK YOU
MISTER LAPIS AND WE TO HAVE
ONE- PRIMARY WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION. MODERATOR IF YOU
CAN PLEASE CONNECT US WITH MARK
PETS WHO IS HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE AMERICAN FOREST AND PAPER
ASSOCIATION. GOOD AFTERNOON
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE. THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK TODAY
MY NAME IS MARKETS AN EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR WITH THE AMERICAN PART
THE PAPERS EDUCATION SPEAKING
IN OPPOSITION OF AB SIX SIX
ONE. HEY CAN BE A REPRESENTS
MANUFACTURERS OF MANY OF THE
PRODUCTS INCLUDED IN THE SCOPE
OF EIGHTY SIX SIX ONE. WE
SUPPORT PROCUREMENT POLICIES
ADVANCED PRODUCT AVAILABILITY
BUT OUR MEMBERS ARE COMMITTED
TO CONTINUOUS IMPROVEMENT IN
ENVIRONMENTAL PERFORMANCE FOR
THE PRODUCTS THAT WE MAKE. BUT
EIGHTY SIX SIX ONE WOULD HAVE
THE OPPOSITE ENVIRONMENTAL
ATTACKS THAN INTENDED. THE
COMMON PERCEPTION THAT
INCREASING THE USE OF RECOVERED
PAPER TRANSLATES INTO BETTER
ENVIRONMENTAL OUTCOMES IS
FLAWED. THERE'S NO DEBATE THAT
DIVERTING PAPER FROM LANDFILL
AND RECOVERING IT COULD RE USE
AS AN ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS
HOWEVER THE BENEFITS OF
REPLACING BURKE CHEN PARTNER
WITH RECYCLED FIBER IN PAPER
PRODUCTS CAN VARY WIDELY
DEPENDING ON THE MANUFACTURING
METHODS. IN THE PRODUCTS
PRODUCED. TO UNDERSTAND WHY THE
MINIMUM POST CONSUMER CONTENT.
AND PUTTING PAPER INCREASE
WOULD HAVE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES WE NEED TO
RECOGNIZE THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN PAPER QUALITY AND HOW
FICKLE. WORKS ALONG THE GROUND.
PUTTING PAPER FOR EXAMPLE IS
VERY HIGH ON THE QUALITY
PYRAMID OF PAPER IT'S BRIGHT
WHITE AND CLEAN AND REQUIRES
HIGH QUALITY INPUTS. THERE ARE
ONLY CERTAIN PARTS RECOVERED
FIBRE STREAM THAT COULD BE USED
CONNECT PUTTING PAPER FOR
EXAMPLE FULL CORRUGATED
CONTAINERS ARE NOT SUITABLE FOR
MAKING PUTTING PAPERS BUT THEY
ALSO REPRESENT OVER 70% OF
RECOVERED BY THE NEXT. AT LEAST
TALK TO MAKE HIGH QUALITY
PRINTING PAPERS POST CONSUMER
RECOVERED FIBER IS THE MOST
CONTAMINATED AND REQUIRES THE
MOST PROCESS INTENSITY OF ALL
THE COVERAGE BY WITH BAILABLE
TRIBUTES- ALSO QUALITY AND
PERFORMANCE TRADEOFFS THAT
OCCUR WHEN BERGEN FIVE ALREADY
PLAGUED BY RESTOCKING WATER.
RECYCLED FIBERS OF SHORTER WE
CARE LESS ABSORBENT AND NOT AS
TO THE VIRGIN BIRTH FRESH FIBER.
THE RESULT OF EIGHTY SIX SIX
ONE WOULD BE TO FORCE POST
CONSUMER RECOVERED FIBRE IN
PRETTY PAPER WHEN THAT VERY
FIBER COULD BE USED MUCH MORE
COST EFFECTIVELY AND WITH THE
LOWER ENVIRONMENTAL FOOTPRINT.
OTHER PRODUCTS LIKE PACKAGES
THAT DON'T REQUIRE SUCH HIGH
QUALITY INPUTS. THE POST
CONSUMER DISTINCTION IS ALSO A
LEGACY TERM THAT SHOULD BE
ELIMINATED. SINGLING OUT POST
CONSUMER FIBER IS PRESUMABLY
BETTER PARDON ARE MAINLY
SUPERIOR TO OTHER RECOVERED
FIBER IN THE SUPPLY CHAIN
CREATED DISTORTED VIEW OF THE
ADVANTAGES OF USING RECYCLED
FIBER. TODAY'S COLLECTION OF
RECOVERED PAPER MIXES BOTH PRE
AND POST CONSUMER MATERIAL
TOGETHER MAKING IT VIRTUALLY
IMPOSSIBLE TO DETERMINE THE
AMOUNT OF POST CONSUMER CONTENT
IN RECOVERED PAPER THAT ARRIVES
AT PAPER MILLS. THAT'S A KEY
REASON WHY BOTH MAJOR THIRD
PARTY- CHAIN OF CUSTODY
CERTIFICATION STANDARDS OF
PAPER PRODUCTS THAT THAT THAT'S
THE PATH THAT BY ELIMINATED THE
POST CONSUMER AT THE
DESIGNATION IN FAVOR OF
RECYCLED CONTENT. FURTHERMORE
THE HIGHEST QUALITY AND MOST
EFFICIENT PART OF THE RECOVERED
FIBRE MIXED USE THE BIG
COMPLAINING PAPER BASED ON
CREDITS CRAP THAT WE CALL HOPE
SUBSTITUTES. THIS IS PAPER THAT
NEED NO SORTING HARDEST
PROCESSING CAN BE DIRECTLY FED
INTO A PAPER MACHINE SB SIX SIX
ONE WITH ELIMINATE THIS RAW
MATERIAL INPUT BECAUSE. IT IS
NOT CONSIDERED CLOSE CONSUMER.
SACRAMENTO FAX ALSO NEED
CONSISTENT TO MAKE PAPER
INSPECTION BUT- I THOUGHT
PEOPLE FOR PAPER MANUFACTURERS
TO DESIGN PRODUCTS COMMITTEE
BALTIMORE RECYCLE CONTENT
REQUIREMENTS DEPENDING ON STATE.
FEDERAL PROCUREMENT FOR TISSUE
AND POWER PRODUCTS FOR EXAMPLE
ALIGNED WITH THE GREEN SEAL
CERTIFICATION STANDARDS WHICH
INCLUDES A MULTI STAKEHOLDER
INPUT. THAT CONSIDERS BOTH
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS AS WELL
AS PRODUCT PERFORMANCE WAITED A
RECYCLED MINIMUM CONTENT
WITHOUT KNOWING THE EFFECTS ON
STRENGTHENING ABSORBENCY OF
THESE PRODUCTS COULD RESULT IN
TOTALLY UNACCEPTABLE PRODUCTS.
ALIGNING WITH THE GREENVILLE
STANDARDS FOR SANITARY PRODUCTS
WOULD SOLVE THAT PROBLEM. IN
SUMMARY WHILE WELL INTENDED SB
SIX SIX ONE IS CHECKING
YESTERDAY'S ENVIRONMENTAL
CHALLENGES AND NOT RECOGNIZING
TODAY'S RECYCLING THE
ELEPHANT'S. POLICIES THAT
MANDATE RECYCLE CONTENT MAY BE
HELPFUL TO JUMP START RECYCLING
FOR PRODUCTS THAT ARE LOW IN
RECOVERY RATES BUT NOT
APPROPRIATE FOR PRODUCTS WITH
HIGHER RATES AND ROBUST MARKETS
THAT IS THE CASE. FOR PAPER
PRODUCTS. BUT ARBITRARILY
RAISING THE MINIMUM POST
CONSUMER RECYCLED CONTENT IN
CERTAIN PAPER PRODUCTS EIGHTY
SIX SIXTY ONE BUT ACTUALLY
INCREASE WAIST. CRAZY ENERGY
CONSUMPTION MUCH OF WHICH COMES
FROM FOSSIL FUELS AND INCREASE
MANUFACTURING COST. RECYCLING
MATERIAL THAT COULD BE PUT TO
GREATER AND MORE EFFICIENT USE
THAT OTHER PAPER PRODUCTS SUCH
AS PAPER BOXES AND
CONTAINERBOARD BECAUSE OF THE
VOCAL NEGATIVE CONSEQUENCES WE
OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND CONSIDERATION OF
THIS IMPORTANT MATTER. HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU
MISTER PETS A MODERATOR IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE ON THE LINE
WISHING TO SPEAK CAN EITHER
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF. AB
SIX SIX ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. ONE TWENTY ONE
FIFTY FIVE. ONE MOMENT ONE
TWENTY ONE FIFTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MELISSA ROMERO AT THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT.
NINE TWENTY ONE SEVENTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GET OFF ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PRODUCT STEWARDSHIP
CAMPBELL IN SUPPORT THANK YOUNG.
AND ONE MOMENT FOR A LAST
COMMENT. ONE TWENTY ONE FORTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO TERRY MEMBERS
BRIDGET MCHALE B. HAPPENS WE
THINK WASTE IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENT IN THE SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION TO. THANK YOU
MODERATOR IS THERE ANYONE
WISHING TO TESTIFY FROM THE
REVOTE REMOTE VIDEO ROOM. SEEN
NONE ANYONE IN THE HEARING ROOM
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF OPPOSITION C. NINE OFFERING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. I
HAVE SO I DO HAVE A QUESTION-
AFTER LISTENING TO THE CALL THE
COMMENTS OF THE MISTER PETS AND
I DID SORT OF A PERFECT
APPRECIATED. HIS DETAILED DIVE
INTO THAT THE WORLD OF PAPER
AND QUALITY AND HOW THAT. HOW
THAT THE IMPLICATIONS OF THAT
FOR A PROPOSAL SUCH AS THIS.
NOW MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT.
THIS BILL IS UPDATING PRODUCTS
AND MINIMUM RECYCLED CONTENT
PERCENTAGES AS DETERMINED TO BE
APPROPRIATE WHICH WOULD BEGIN
ON JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE THERE WILL BE A PROCESS
FOR ESTABLISHING THEIR
STANDARDS AND DEFINITIONS
CORRECT. YES YES END DATE THE
ISSUES THAT HE BROUGHT UP WERE
FAIRLY TECHNICAL AND FAIRLY
NARROW ABOUT YOU KNOW PERFECTLY
RECYCLED AND- WE CERTAINLY ARE
ARE PRETENDING THAT WE CAN WITH
THIS BILL IDENTIFY ALL OF THE
SPECIFICS IN THE COMPLICATED
WORLD OF RECYCLING AND ETCETERA
NOR CAN WE ANTICIPATE ALL THE
CHANGES SO THAT'S WHY THIS BILL
SETS UP EVERY THREE YEAR
UPDATING SO THAT WE DON'T GET
OURSELVES IN THE SITUATION THAT
WE'RE IN RIGHT NOW- AND-
CERTAINLY IT WE ARE CERTAINLY
WILLING TO ENTERTAIN AMENDMENTS
IF- THERE AMENDMENTS SO FAR WE
HAVE NOT RECEIVED ANY- ANY
AMENDMENT SUGGESTIONS. TO
ADDRESS ANY PARTICULAR ISSUE
BUT HELLO THIS BILL DOES THE
STANDARDS THAT ARE ADOPTED ARE
THE ONES THAT ARE THE FEDERAL
EPA STANDARDS OF BECAUSE IT
SEEMS BEST FOR US TO STAY
CONSISTENT IT MAKES IT EASIER
FOR EVERYBODY IN THE RECYCLING
MARKET- TO WORK IF WE HAVE A
COMMON STANDARD- NATIONALLY-
THAT IS OUT THERE SO AND THEN
IN ADDITION TO THAT WE HAVE TO
AGENCIES THAT WILL BE DIRECTED
TO SORT OF COORDINATE ALL THE
RULE MAKING. ON THIS AND THERE
WILL BE A SIGNIFICANT
RULEMAKING THAT WILL WILL HAVE
TO HAVE TO TAKE PLACE AND
THAT'LL TAKE PLACE OFCOURSE
WITH ALL OF THE APPROPRIATE
PUBLIC COMMENT X. CENTER THAT
GOES FOR WITH OTHER RULEMAKINGS
HI THIS IS AN ATTEMPT TO SORT
OF START THAT WHOLE PROCESS-
AND SORT OF BRING IT BACK UP TO
SPEED WITH THE EPA STANDARDS AS
WE KNOW THEM NOW BUT
RECOGNIZING THEIR STILL QUITE A
BIT OF- SUCH SPECIFIC WORK THAT
WOULD NEED TO BE DONE. THANK
YOU FOR THAT AND ALSO THAT YOU
DID MENTION SOMETHING THAT I
WANTED TO PUT I THINK IN OUR
INITIAL COMMITTEE ANALYSIS WE
HAD MENTIONED THAT WE THOUGHT
THAT THERE SHOULD BE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR PUBLIC REVIEW
AND COMMENT BOB WE'D NO LONGER
THINK THE BILL NEEDS TO BE
AMENDED TO REFLECT THAT BECAUSE
THAT IS ALREADY A PART OF THAT
THE PROCESSOR I WANTED
KNOWLEDGE THAT AND THAT AND
THANK YOU FOR IT SOUNDS LIKE
YOU'RE COMMITMENT FOR
CONTINUING CHANGE ENGAGE WITH.
OPPOSITION OR STAKEHOLDERS TO
ENSURE THAT SOME OF THE. BY THE
COMPLEXITY IN THE DETAIL ALL.
REFLECT THE THREE ON THE GROUND
JUST TRYING TO DO GOOD
GOVERNMENT HERE IF SOMEBODY CAN
COME UP WITH A GOOD GOVERNMENT
IMPROVEMENT WE'RE CERTAINLY
HAPPY TO THE INTERNET TO LOOK
ENTERTAIN THANK YOU FOR THAT
WOULD WITH THAT WOULD YOU LIKE
TO. ASSEMBLY MEMBER. BOB SHOW
OF DISRESPECT WE ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH RIGHT
THANK YOU AND I THINK WE NEED.
A VERY WE NEED A MOTION. MAYOR
OF TO FIVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEDINA AND- I WILL THE SECOND
FROM MS BURKE. OKAY AB MADAM
SECRETARY IF YOU WOULD PLEASE.
AT THE MOTION IS TO PASS A
REPORT TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS PETRIE-NORRIS HI
PETRIE-NORRIS I- SEN. BURKE
BURKE AYE GRAY. LACKING LACKEY
LACKEY NULL MEDINA MEDINA I
RODRIGUEZ. THANK YOU SO AT
THREE ZERO WE WILL AT A SORRY
THREE ONE. THREE ONE WE WILL
THAT THAT BILLS ON CALL AND
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR OTHER
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER ABOUT
IT. AND I SEE OKAY MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM TEN AB SEVEN SEVEN
SEVEN. THE VERY LUCKY BELL
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY THAT'S
BETTER THAN SICK SICK SICK IT
IS MUCH BETTER IT'S MUCH BETTER.
YES- YES- THIS ADVENTURE IS A
IS A DISTRICT FAILED RELATE TO
SOON TO BE SURPLUS PROPERTY IN
OUR DISTRICT FOR THOSE OF YOU
THAT BEEN AROUND THERE THE UC
DAVIS MED CENTER JUST HERE ON
THE JUST SOUTH AND EAST OF HERE
HAS THE STATE BUILDING THE
DEPARTMENT GENERALS SERVICES
HAS A CRIME LAB THERE IN THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET IT- COMING OUT A
FEW WEEKS DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS LOOKING TO MOVE THAT TO A
DIFFERENT LOCATION HERE IN
SACRAMENTO SO THE STATE LAND-
WILL BE SURPLUS AND THIS WOULD
ALLOCATED FOR. TWO HIGH PROFILE
ISSUES FOR MY DISTRICT AND THE
STATE HIGHER EDUCATION ACCESS
AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND THIS
IS AN OFF CAMPUS CENTER HERE IN
SACRAMENTO THE- MEDICAL SCHOOL
NURSES SCHOOL MOVED FROM DAVIS
YEARS AGO- WHEN YOU SEE THAN
CSU'S GROW IN COMMUNITIES THEY
ARE OBLIGATED TO BUILD HOUSING
IN THOSE COMMUNITIES THINK OF
UC IRVINE DAVIS UCLA AND
BERKELEY WHEN THEY BUILD OFF
CAMPUS CENTERS THEY ARE ALWAYS
REQUIRED TO DO SO- INFLUX OF
STUDENTS CAN- DISPLACED
RESIDENTS RIGHT WE'RE ALREADY
SEEING THAT HERE IN SACRAMENTO
WITH THE HOUSING MARKET IN THE
BAY AREA. IMPACTED PEOPLE
COMING IN SO THIS WILL BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE AN AFFORDABLE A
STUDENT HOUSING OPTION FOR THAT
STUDENTS GROWING HERE THE
SACRAMENTO CAMPUS AS WELL AS
PROTECT THE SURROUNDING AREAS I
DO- THE CONCUR WITH YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND WILL ACCEPT YOUR
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS TO MAKE
SURE WE HAVE SAFEGUARDS IN
PLACE TO MAKE SURE THE LAND
GOES TO OUR INTENDED PURPOSE
AND IF IT DOESN'T HE WOULD
WOULD BE BURKE BACK T DGS FOR
OTHER PURPOSES. HI THIS BILL
AGAIN WOULD HELP US MEET-
HIGHER EDUCATION GOALS IN OUR
REGION AND OUR STATE AS WELL
AS- HOUSING- HOUSING- GOALS IN
OUR COMMUNITY AND HOUSING NEEDS
FRANKLY IN OUR COMMUNITY AS
WELL- LASTLY- WE'RE COMMITTED
TO WORK WITH SKILLED SKILLED
LABOR TRADES TO MAKE SURE THAT
LABOR STANDARDS ARE FAIR. FOR
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS IN THE
SACRAMENTO AREA. HERE ME TO
TESTIFY IS KENDRA LEWIS WITH
SECOND HOUSE ALLIANCE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY A MODERATOR IF YOU CAN
PLEASE CONNECT US WITH MS LEWIS.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYONE CAN HEAR ME
YES. BUT I'M THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK BEFORE YOU
TODAY- I COME BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE ASKING FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AT EIGHT LUCKY AB SEVEN
SEVEN SEVEN I SUPPORT THIS BILL
BECAUSE IT ENSURES THAT WHEN
THE DOJ PROPERTY BECOME VACANT
IT WILL BE USED BY THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA DAVIS FOR
AFFORDABLE STUDENT HOUSING
HOUSING. WHICH IS WHICH IS GOOD
FOR OUR U. FIFTEEN AND OUR
LOCAL COMMUNITY A PORTABLE
HOUSING- AFFORDABLE STUDENT
HOUSING NEAR CAMPUS IS CRITICAL
AND ALLOW STUDENT POPULATION
AND THE COMMUNITY THAT TO
THRIVE TOGETHER WITH EIGHTY
SEVEN SEVEN SEVEN WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO USE ACCESS PLANS
AND PROTECT THE SURROUNDING
COMMUNITY FROM DISPLACEMENT AND
GENTRIFICATION. AS A MEMBER OF
THE GREATER SACRAMENTO
COMMUNITY AND SOMEONE WHO WORKS
DALY. FIGHT FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IN OUR REGION. AND WORK
WORKING. STUDENTS OF. AT AN AS
A MOTHER OF A WORKING CLASS
MOTHER DO THAT SEVEN THE STATE
AND YOU SEE RIVERSIDE I KNOW
FIRST HAND THE COFFEE STRUGGLE.
THAT FAMILIES AND COMMUNITY
MEMBERS. BUT CONTEND WITH
REGARDING HOUSING- BUT WHAT
BLACK OF A FORTY PORTABLE
HOUSING THE YEAR MY DAUGHTER
WAS A FRESHMAN AT THE END OF
THE STATE- THERE WAS NOT ENOUGH
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR STUDENTS
AND MANY STUDENTS WERE FORCED.
TO HAVE TO PUT OFF THE FRESHMAN
YEAR OF COLLEGE AND THAT
HAPPENED THROUGHOUT OUR STATE.
MY FOCUS ON THIS CRISIS AND DO
BETTER EIGHTY SEVEN SEVEN SEVEN
IF NECESSARY TO ENSURE THAT
THIS SPECIFIC PROPERTIES USED
TO KEEP HOUSING CRISIS YOUR
DOCTOR NEAR THE. SACRAMENTO
FELT CAMPUS- I'M SORRY HERE THE
FACT THAT. A FEW DAYS CAMP. AND
MAKE IT WHERE THE NEARBY
COMMUNITY HAS. YOU HAVE
TERRIBLE OUT- IS IT WILL ABOUT
THE COMMUNITY THAT HAS REELED
FROM REDLINE HISTORY I ASK YOU
FOR YOUR SUPPORT EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SEVEN PLEASE I APOLOGIZE
RIGHT. THANK YOU MR S. AT
MODERATORS THERE ANYONE ELSE ON
THE LINE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
EITHER SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF AB SEVEN SEVEN
SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN GENERAL AT THIS TIME. NINE
TWENTY ONE FIFTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MA'AM CHEN MEMBERS THIS IS ROSS
BARKLEY ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF SACRAMENTO IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVEN SEVEN SEVEN THANKS. NINE
TWENTY ONE SIXTY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
TWENTY ONE SIXTY FOUR YOU MAY
BE ON YOUTH MUTE PLEASE GO
AHEAD BY. I AM CALLING TO
OPPOSE A. B. ONE THREE ONE SIX.
OKAY WILL MAKE A NOTE OF THAT I
THINK IT MIGHT BE THE WRONG
IT'S ACTUALLY THE WRONG HEARING
THAT WAS THE END BILL HERE.
FIVE HOURS AGO. OKAY THANK YOU.
AND THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENT ON THE SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION TO THANK YOU I SIR
ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY FROM
THE REMOTE VIDEO RAM SEEN NONE
ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION IN THE
HEARING ROOM C. NINE QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
MR LACKEY- AS THEY ARE UTAH
STATE AGGIES- ALARM I HAVE A
HARD TIME OPPOSING ANYTHING
THAT'S CALLED THE AGGIE SQUARE
PROJECT- IN ALL SERIOUSNESS
THIS DOES. ADDRESS A PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT PROBLEM AND I THINK
IT'S A REASONABLE SUGGESTION TO
ADDRESS A VERY SERIOUS PROBLEM
AND SOLVE THE SUPPORTING THE
BILL. MISTER MEDINA TO THE
AUTHOR. HOW BIG IS THE PARTIAL.
THANK YOU IT'S A TWENTY FIVE
ACRE PARCEL SO IT'S LIKE A
SIGNIFICANT PIECE OF LAND AND
IF HE HAD ANY TYPE OF DECENT
DENSITY THERE LIKE YOU HAVE
BEEN WE'VE SEEN THAT- UC'S
ACROSS THE STATE. YOU COULD
BUILD UP BETWEEN HI HUNDREDS UP
TO OVER A THOUSAND HOUSING
UNITS THERE. WHICH WOULD HELP
ACCOMMODATE THEIR GROWTH TO
SACRAMENTO AS WELL AS ADDRESS
POTENTIAL DISPLACEMENT IN THE
SURROUNDING NEIGHBORHOODS. AND
I'LL JOIN IN WITH THE BY A
COLLEAGUE DAY AGGIE- AND IN
THAT WE KNOW WHAT A SERIOUS
PROBLEM I WAS IN IS-
ESPECIALLY- FOR. INSTITUTIONS
OF HIGHER EDUCATION. AND THIS
ONE- IS INTENDED FOR BOTH
STUDENTS. FACULTY STAFF AS WELL
AS- MAKING IT AVAILABLE ALSO
FOR- LOW INCOME- AFFORDABLE
HOUSING CORRECT I NOT NOT IN
THIS VERSION RIGHT NOW RIGHT
NOW IT'S BROAD BUT WE'RE GOING
TO FOCUS SOLELY ON STUDENTS
OKAY BECAUSE THERE ARE TWENTY
THOUSAND EMPLOYEES THERE RIGHT
NOW AND THEY COULD TAKE TEN
MINUTES WITHOUT THOSE UNITS
RIGHT AWAY NOT REALLY. FOCUS ON
THE THIRD NEED AND HE YOU KNOW
MR MEDINA HIGHER RED CHAIR
WE'RE LOOKING AT EXPANDING YOU
SEE ACCESS WE HAVE A RECORD
NUMBER OF PEOPLE APPLYING TO
THE NINE UNDERGRADUATE UC'S
AND- WE DON'T HAVE SPACE AT ALL
OF OUR CAMPUSES SO IF WE CAN BE
CREATIVE AND EXPAND CAPACITY AT
THE OFF CAMPUS CENTERS LIKE
BERKELEY'S GONDOLA MILLS
COLLEGE. BAKER LOOKING AT HERE
THAT HELPS EXPAND THAT THAT
HERE IN SACRAMENTO BUT ALSO THE
DO IT FREES UP SPACE IN DAVIS
TO ENROLL MORE QUALIFIED HIGH
SCHOOL KIDS WHO ARE GRADUATING.
READY TO GO DO YOU SEE AND THEY
DON'T HAVE A SPOT FOR THEM. A
GREAT USE OF LAND YEP THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SEE NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WHICH LIKE TO CLOSER. I
THINK THAT COULD BE A CLOSE
THANK YOU BROUGHT IT HOME ALL
RIGHT I THINK DO WE HAVE WE'VE
GOT A DID WE HAVE A MOTION AND
A SECOND. YES WE HAVE. A MOTION
FOR SOME A MEMBER BURKE SECOND
FROM ASSEMBLYMEMBER LACKEY.
BOTTOM SECRETARY LEE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS A DO
PATH AS AMENDED AND REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
PETRI NORRIS I PETRIE-NORRIS HI
PATTERSON BURKE BURKE I GRADE
LACKEY LACKEY HI MEDINA MEDINA
I RODRIGUEZ. FOUR ZERO THAT
FILLED OUT AND WILL LEAVE THE
ROLL UP AND FOR OTHERS TO ADD
ON. THANK YOU. LIVING ON THE
FILE ITEM TWELVE AB EIGHT NINE
THIRTY FOUR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COOLEY WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
AND MOVE UP THE- YEAH THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS I'M
DELIGHTED TO BRING AB NINE
THIRTY FOR YOU AND THIS
ACTUALLY RELATES TO IN A BACK
DOOR SOARED AWAY WITH THE ANNEX
PROJECT THE PIECE OF THEIR NEXT
PROJECT I'VE BEEN WORKING ON
MORE THAN ANYTHING ELSE IS MORE
THAN FOUR YEARS OLD AT THIS
POINT AND IT'S A SECURITY
CONVERSATION. I STARTED THE
SECURITY CONVERSATION VERY VERY
EARLY BECAUSE I KNEW THAT IF WE
WAITED THE LAST MINUTE TO DO
WHAT'S ISSUES OF SECURITY. IT
WOULD BE SO MUCH MORE EXPENSIVE.
BECAUSE IN HAVE A LOT OF CHANGE
ORDERS AND THEY WERE JUST SAID
THE COST OF THE ROOF. THIS BILL
BENEFITS THAT SAME PATTERN THIS
DEALS WITH SOMETHING VERY
IMPORTANT NOT A SHELTER IN
PLACE IN A BUILDING. EDIT ASK
TEACHERS TO DO A STUDY AND
BRING FORTH GUIDELINES ON HOW
WE SHOULD DEAL WITH SHELTER IN
PLACE. AND THE PURPOSE OF THIS
IS ISN'T THERE FOR ANOTHER
STUDY BILL. BUT THE ROLE OF
THIS STUDY BILL IS TO GET ON
EVERYONE'S RADAR SCREEN WHAT
ARE GOOD PRACTICES ON CHILDREN
PLACE. SO AS WE ARE DEVELOPING
PLANS FOR BUILDINGS REFERRED
INTEGRATED IN EARLY. AND THAT
MAKES US LESS EXPENSIVE SHORT
IN A PLACE IS AN INTERESTING
CONCEPT THERE ARE DIFFERENT
VARIETIES OF IT. THE RESULT IN
PLACE IN NEW CONSTRUCTION.
WHICH CAN DEAL WITH SUCH THINGS
AS- THE IDEA IS IF SOMETHING
BAD HAPPENS. WHERE CAN YOU GET
TO. SO THIS IS NOT A NEW
CONVERSATION SINCE JANUARY SIX
ON JANUARY SIX IT MAKES US ALL
THINK ABOUT IT DIFFERENTLY. R.
BUT IT'S WHAT IS THE WHAT MAKES
FOR A SHELTER IN PLACE WHAT
SORT OF RESILIENCE TO THAT PART
OF THE BUILDING NEED TO HAVE.
TO DEAL WITH RESISTANCE ARE
THERE SYSTEMS COMMUNICATION
SYSTEMS. ALARM SYSTEMS. IS
THERE SOME NEED TO HAVE SOME
SORT OF. BATHROOMS OR WATER OR
THOSE SORTS OF THINGS THESE ARE
ALL ELEMENTS TO KIND OF FIT
INTO. A NEW CONSTRUCTION. IT'S
ALSO RELEVANT IF YOU'RE
ACTUALLY DOING A PROJECT
AROUND. OLDER MORE VULNERABLE
CONSTRUCTION. HOW CAN PEOPLE
GET FROM A FOLDER STRUCTURE
INTO A- SAFE AND SECURE PLACE.
WHERE PEOPLE THE NOTED GO LOOK.
IF SOMETHING HAPPENS. SO THIS
IS- IT IS A SMALL TOPIC BUT I
THINK IT'S ONE THAT'S PER MUCH
AFFECT WITH THE PUBLIC
INTEREST. IN PUBLIC BUILDINGS
IT IS ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE- YOU KNOW. AS WE
ARRIVED HERE IS MEMBERS CENTERS
ARE STAFFERS YOUNG PEOPLE IT IS
SORT OF THE PUZZLE PALACE
FINDING YOUR WAY AROUND THIS
BUILDING IS CONFUSING. BUT PITY
THE POOR PUBLIC CREWS HERE. YOU
KNOW CAN'T SEE A WINDOW CAN'T
ORIENT THEMSELVES POLITE. YOU
KNOW WHERE THE STAIRCASE IS HOW
THE FORCE CONNECT I MEAN THIS
IS A VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE IN
PUBLIC BUILDINGS KIND OF
ANTICIPATE THIS NEED SO. THAT
IS THE ISSUE I'M DELIGHTED TO
BRING IT FORWARD I THANK YOU
FOR THE- MOTION AND THE SECOND
HOMES AND IS DESIGNED NOT TO
JUST ASK DID YOU HAVE TO
REINVENT THE WHEEL BUT TO TAKE
BILL WOULD ACTUALLY OF WHAT
FEMA HAS DONE. THERE IS
OUTSTANDING WORK BUT I'VE BEEN
FOLLOWING AND- BEEN IN THE
WEEDS ON FOR SOME YEARS. FEMA
US DEPARTMENT STATE DEPARTMENT
OF DEFENSE HOME SECURITY
THEY'VE ALL DONE SORT OF WORK.
SOLVE THE PUZZLE OF HOW TO KEEP
PEOPLE SAFE IS NOT AS MURKY. AS
IT WAS TWENTY YEARS AGO. AND SO
I THINK IT'S JUST A- A GOOD
TIME FOR CALIFORNIA WEATHER
APARTMENT. SKIP THE CREAM OFF
THAT LEARNING BRING IT TO US
AND LET YOU JUST WORK AND- TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF IT. I THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COOLEY. AT MODERATOR I BELIEVE
WE HAVE BEEN I DON'T THINK WE
HAVE ANY PRIMARY WITNESSES AND
EITHER SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION.
BOB BUT IF YOU PLEASE OPEN UP
THE MAIN LINE IF THERE'S ANY.
ADDITIONAL. SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF
EIGHTY. NINE THIRTY FOUR YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WITH NO ONE IN QUEUE
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU I'VE-
MOVING TO OUR REMOTE VIDEO
TESTIMONY ROOM IS THERE ANYONE
WISHING TO TESTIFY. NEXT SCENE.
IS THERE ANYONE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN THE HEARING ROOM
SCENE NINE BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS. CNN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE REQUESTED
AYE VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE PRIVILEGE OF BEING HERE
THANK YOU WE'VE GOT A MOTION-
FROM ASSEMBLYMEMBER LACKEY IN A
SEC A SECOND FROM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MEDINA. BOTTOM SECRETARY
FEEL PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS PETRIE-NORRIS HI
PETRIE-NORRIS HI PATTERSON.
BURKE BURKE I GRADE LACKEY
LACKEY I MEDINA MEDINA I
RODRIGUEZ. FOUR ZERO THAT FELL
IS OUT AND RELIEVE THE ROLE
OPEN THANK YOU. LET'S SEE I
THINK WE ARE PUTTING OUT A- I
THINK IT MIGHT HAPPEN AUTHOR
JOINING US- NURSING. HI HELLO
IT IS EXCEPT FOR A ONE NIGHT
YOUR HONOR BOB THANK YOU I WAS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH PERFECT.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US THE
SELLER MEMBERS RIGHT THANK YOU
FOR. THE BILL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I'M PRESENTING AB THIRTEEN
FIFTY EIGHT ON BEHALF OF
ATTORNEY GENERAL BONTA. THE
COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS
CLEARLY HIGHLIGHTED SO MANY
DISPARITIES. N. AND ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITIES BUT THE ESPECIALLY
IN COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. THE
PANDEMIC HAS PARTICULARLY
HIGHLIGHTED THE INEQUITIES
WITHIN. AND BROUGHT TO LIGHT
THE TREMENDOUS DIVERSITY WITHIN
THE- THE WIDE RANGE OF ASIAN OR
PACIFIC ISLANDER COMMUNITIES
AND THAT WE SAW THAT THE- THAT
THE PANDEMIC- RATES- THE CODE
RATES. FOR EXAMPLE WERE
SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER IN
COMMUNITIES LIKE A THE FILIPINO
COMMUNITY THE VIETNAMESE
COMMUNITY- THE NATIVE HAWAIIAN
AND PACIFIC ISLANDER
COMMUNITIES AND ALOT OF THIS
WAS NEVER COVERED. IN THE NEWS-
AND- YOU KNOW I WAS JUST
LUMPED IN WITH THE DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT HOW RATES IN THE API
COMMUNITIES WERE LOWER THAN AN
AFRICAN AMERICAN AND LATINO
COMMUNITIES SO THAT THAT'S JUST
ONE OF MANY EXAMPLES OF AND
WHAT THIS BILL IS TRYING TO
ADDRESS- TO MAKE SURE THAT
THOSE. PUBLIC HEALTH
DISPARITIES IN OUR TARGETED
UNDERSTOOD AND RESPONDED TO A
PROPERLY- I AM. A PRESENTED
THIS BILL- WITH THE SUPPORT OF
THE WITNESSES WHO ARE KIM
RHODES ASSOCIATE PROFESSOR OF
EPIDEMIOLOGY. AT THE OFFICE OF
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT AND JULIA
WHO WITH THE ASIAN HEALTH
SERVICES THE SPONSOR OF THIS
BILL. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SIXTY FIVE AND OPERATOR
MODERATOR IF YOU CAN PLEASE
CONNECT US WITH MIS READ. OF
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS EVA
PART OUT- I IN AND GETTING I
DON'T KNOW IF I AM I SHOULD BE
ON THERE- BUT I'M STANDING AT
THE WITNESS. OKAY WONDERFUL ARE
YOU AT WHERE YOU JOINING US
FROM. I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
OPERATIONS FOR AMERICA HEALTH
AND JOINING YOU FROM- RIGHT NOW
I MEAN THE CALIFORNIA FROM THE
BAY AREA. AND ARE YOU HERE TO
TESTIFY ON BEHALF OF THE AB
THIRTEEN FIFTY EIGHT. YES OKAY.
ALL RIGHT. WELCOME ALL RIGHT
OKAY. THANK YOU TO THE MIX
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR BRINGING
AB THIRTEEN FIFTY EIGHT FOR
DISCUSSION MY NAME IS EVA PART
OKAY I AM THE DIRECTOR OF
OPERATIONS FOR A MO JEFF HELLO
A COALITION OF MORE THAN FORTY
ORGANIZATIONS OPERATING IN
ALAMEDA COUNTY SAN FRANCISCO
AND SAN MATTEO. WE'RE NOW
HELPING PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT BREAK BARRIERS TO
REACH THE MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS INCLUDING THE BLACK
LATINO AND PACIFIC ISLANDER
COMMUNITY- NOT A CLINIC WHAT WE
HAVE SUCCESSFULLY GOTTEN
RESOURCES TO DELIVER OR
NAVIGATE COMMUNITY MEMBERS. TO
OVER THREE THOUSAND KOVIN
NINETEEN TESTS AND THREE
THOUSAND BACK BEING. WE
PIONEERED THE NEIGHBORHOOD POP
UP MODEL ADOPTED AND
IMPLEMENTED BY PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT IN BOTH SAN
FRANCISCO IN ALAMEDA COUNTY. WE
OFFER SUPPORT AT EIGHTY
THIRTEEN FIFTY EIGHT BECAUSE
OUR WORK AND REVEALED THE FEAR
LIMITS ON THE DATA WE HAVE TO
GEICO THE NINETEEN CONTROL
STRATEGIES. WHEN WE FIRST
STARTED TESTING THERE WAS NO
JENNIFER METHOD OF COLLECTING
GREAT THAT'S NITTY DATA ON
INSPECTIONS OR DEATH. IS
HAMPERED OUR ABILITY TO TARGET
INTERVENTIONS FOR COMMUNITIES
THAT NEED IT THE MOST. I WORK
ALSO BECAUSE THE IMPACT OF
OCCUPATION AND COBIT NINETEEN
INFECTIONS. IT IS CLEAR THAT
SOME WORK PLACES ARE SOURCE OF
INFECTION WHICH ONE BROUGHT
HOME TO THE LOCAL COMMUNITY BY
CENTRAL WORKERS EXPONENTIALLY
INCREASES. SPREADING
POPULATIONS WHO MAY LIVE IN
CROWDED HOUSEHOLD. OCCUPATIONAL
DATA ARE CURRENTLY EXCLUDED
FROM ROUTINE COLLECTION AND
REPORTING- ALSO ADVOCATING FOR
BETTER DATA TO INFORM TO HELP
REPLACEMENT INDEX BECAUSE IT
FAILED TO ACCOUNT FOR THE
DISADVANTAGE OF SPEAKING
ENGLISH AS A SECOND LANGUAGE.
OR LIVING IN A LOW RESOURCE
NEIGHBORHOODS LOCATED NEAR
AFFLUENT AREA. HELLO OUTGOING
BELHAVEN NEIGHBORHOOD AND
SALMON TAIL WERE LEFT OUT OF
STATEWIDE EQUITY BASED BACKING
DISTRIBUTION DUE TO PROXIMITY
TO WEALTHIER AREA. AS A RESULT
THE WEALTHY CITIES WITH ZERO
POINT 45% OF THE INFECTION THAT
ALMOST HALF OF THE COUNTY
BACKING WILD BILL HAVEN IN EAST
PALO ALTO BUT THE BULK OF THE
AREA'S CONVECTION INFECTIONS.
BUT LESS THAN 10% IN SUMMARY WE
ARE YOU TO THE I ON BILL THIRTY
FIFTY. IMPROVE RELATED DATA. SO
WE CAN EFFECTIVELY IDENTIFY AND
INTERVENE IN COMMITTEE HARDEST
HIT BY THE PANDEMIC. IT IS NOT
SIMPLY AN ISSUE OF HEALTH
EQUITY IT'S ALSO ABOUT THE
EFFICIENT USE OF PUBLIC HEALTH
DOLLARS. THE RECOMMENDED
CHANGES WILL HELP US BREAK THE
CHAINS OF KOBE NINETEEN
TRANSMISSION IN YOUR
COMMUNITIES AND MINE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM MODERATOR TO WE
HAVE EITHER KIM RHODES OR JULIA
LU IN THE QUEUE TO TESTIFY. WE
HAVE TRULY A LOOP IN THE QUEUE
WONDERFUL. AND OF CAN YOU HEAR
ME. YES WE GOT TWELVE. OKAY
GREAT HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME'S JULIA LIAO AND I'M HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE ASIAN HEALTH
SERVICES ONE OF THE SPONSORS OF
THE BILL WE ARE COMMUNITY
HEALTH CENTER THAT PROVIDES
MEDICAL DENTAL AND MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES TO FIFTY
THOUSAND PATIENTS IN ENGLISH
AND FOURTEEN ASIAN LANGUAGES.
WE'VE PROVIDED OVER THIRTY
SEVEN THOUSAND FREE CALL THE
PAST TEN TWENTY THOUSAND
VACCINATIONS WE COULD NOT HAVE
DONE ALL OF THIS WITHOUT
PROVIDING THESE CRITICAL CODE
SERVICES IN THE LANGUAGES
CENTER COMMUNITY SPEAK. IT DATA
ON LANGUAGE IS NOT COLLECTED IN
A SYSTEMATIC MANNER. ACTOR RENE
A DEFICIENT RELEASED A
STANDARDIZED DISAGGREGATED DATA
RACE AND THIS IS NECESSITY DATA
FOR COMEDIANS OF COLOR. WHICH
IS MATH COMMUNITY WIDE
DISPARITIES FACED BY VULNERABLE
COMMUTER COLOR WHICH IS
ESPECIALLY PRONOUNCED DURING
THE PANDEMIC. AS A RESULT THE
UNDERSTANDING OF THE IMPACT OF
COLLUDED WAS DELAYED AND
REMAINS LIMITED. FOR EXAMPLE
FOR THE LIMITED DATA WE CAN NO
FILIPINO AMERICANS ACCOUNTED
FOR AT LEAST 41% OF CALLED THE
DEATHS AMONG ASIAN AMERICANS IN
CALIFORNIA. YET THEY ONLY
COMPRISE 20% OF THE STATE'S
AGING POPULATION. WE ALSO KNOW
THAT ASIAN AMERICANS HAVE THE
HIGHEST CASE FATALITY RATE IN
CALIFORNIA EIGHT POINT 1%
VERSUS THREE POINT 9% IN THE
ENTIRE STATE. THE RISE IN ANTI
ASIAN RACISM HAS EXACERBATED.
THESE EMERGING DISPARITIES.
DURING OUR CO THE PAST THAT AGE
AND HEALTH SERVICES. WE TOOK
THE INITIATIVE TO COLLECT OUR
OWN DISAGGREGATED DATA AND SAW
THAT THE NEEDS GROUP HAD HIGHER
CUPBOARD POSITIVITY RATE. WHICH
ENABLED US TO DO TARGETED
OUTREACH AND INTERVENTIONS FOR
THIS POPULATION. YOU FEEL A
NEED APPOINTED PACIFIC
GALLAGHER POLICY DATA LAB HAS
DEMONSTRATED THAT THE
APPLICATION OF METRICS TO
DETERMINE HEALTH EQUITY WITH
OUT THIS AGGREGATED DATA
INCLUDING LANGUAGE UNDERSTATES
THE NEEDS OF RACIAL ETHNIC
POPULATION GROUPS THAT ARE
GEOGRAPHICALLY DISPERSED. THIS
BILL WILL BE FOUNDATIONAL THE
BILL BEING THE DISAGGREGATED
DATA INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDED
DURING PUBLIC HEALTH CRISES
MOVING FORWARD AND ENABLE THE
TARGETING OF AFFECTED POLICIES
AND APPLICABLE RESOURCES FOR
OUR MOST VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR. LET US LEARN FROM THE
LESSONS OF COLD IT APPEAR FOR
THE FUTURE HAD TO PAY THE PAST
EVENTS HEALTH EQUITY FOR ALL
COMMUNITIES. WITH FIFTY FOUR
GROUPS FROM AROUND THE STATE
THAT REPRESENTS API AS WELL AS
AN HPI AND BLACK AND WHITE NEXT
GROUPS WE URGE YOU. TO SUPPORT
THE BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISS O. I MODERATOR IF YOU
CANNOT PLEASE OPEN THE LINE FOR
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION A. B.
THIRTEEN FIFTY EIGHT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. NINE
TWENTY ONE SIXTY ONE YOUR MIND
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD HELLO.
HELLO THERE THIS IS. THIS IS A-
OUR CARISSA BBN ON BEHALF OF
THE CENTRAL VALLEY COMMUNITY
INTEGRATION KALEVALA COLLECTIVE
AND CALL FROM CLOVIS CALIFORNIA
AND I'M CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT. NINE TWENTY FIFTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS NOT A SINGLE
COP WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
ONE TWENTY ONE SEVENTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
DURING A LONG AND ON BEHALF OF
AGING RESEARCH THANK WITH
OFFICES IN SACRAMENTO AND LOS
ANGELES AND PARTNERS ACROSS THE
STATE I WANT TO SHARE THAT WE
ARE IN FULL SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTEEN FIFTY EIGHT. THANK YOU.
NINE TWENTY ONE FORTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS ROBIN
GALLAGHER I'M CALLING FROM
GOLDEN VALLEY HEALTH CENTERS
HERE IN MERCER CALIFORNIA UNDER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AT GRAYSON
STRICT AND WE FULLY SUPPORT AB
THIRTEEN FIFTY EIGHT ENERGY TO
PASS THIS BILL. NINE TWENTY ONE
NINETY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS OSCAR SANDOVAL WITH THE WORK
YOU KNOW COALITION FOR A
HEALTHY CALIFORNIA BASED OF
SACRAMENTO WITH PARTNERS ALL OF
THE STATE AND WE'RE CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN FIFTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU. NINE TWENTY
ONE NINETY FIVE. ONE MOMENT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN IT'S WHAT.
THANK YOU HELLO THIS IS SWATI
SHARMA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTHY NAIL SALON
COLLABORATIVE SERVING ORANGE
COUNTY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTEEN FIFTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
NINE TWENTY ONE EIGHTY NINE THE
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS JESSICA HELLO I'M
CALLING FROM NORTHEAST MEDICAL
SERVICES BASED OUT OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA AND WE'RE
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTEEN FIFTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
NINE TWENTY ONE NINETY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS ADAM
CARBURETOR WITH THE ASSOCIATION
OF ASIAN PACIFIC COMMUNITY
HEALTH ORGANIZATIONS ARE AFTER
A BRAND NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
COMMUNITY BASED HEALTHCARE
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING SEVERAL
FEDERALLY QUALIFIED HEALTH
CENTERS IN CALIFORNIA DEDICATED
TO EXPANDING HEALTH ACCESS AND
OUTCOMES FOR MEDICALLY
UNDERSERVED ASIAN AMERICANS
NATIVE HAWAIIANS AND PACIFIC
ISLANDERS AFTER A STRONG
SUPPORT AB THIRTEEN FIFTY EIGHT
AND ENCOURAGES YOU TO VOTE. ON
THE BILL. OPEN COULD GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS AN ENGLAND I'M
CALLING FROM ORANGE COUNTY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KATHI NOTICES
AT DISTRICT I'M I'M WITH THE
ORANGE COUNTY ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER COMMUNITY ALLIANCE AND
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTEEN FIFTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
NINE TWENTY ONE EIGHTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
VICTOR CHRISTY WITH CALIFORNIA
HEALTH BUT THAT THE KIDS
ADVOCATING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA'S COMMUNITY HEALTH
CENTER WE ARE STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NINE TWENTY ONE
NINETY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
DAVID BLACK WHO FOR ONE IT'S
ACTION PROJECT IN FULL SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NINE TWENTY ONE
EIGHTY SEVEN. YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO CLARISSA
SEVEN FROM THE ASIAN AMERICAN
DRUG ABUSE PROGRAM ALSO NOTICE
EIGHT APPS- WE SERVE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY AND WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN
FIFTY EIGHT. NINE TWENTY ONE
NINETY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS CHOICE WE
ARE CALLING ON THE BEHALF OF
ASIAN PACIFIC PARTNERS FOR
EMPOWERMENT ADVOCACY AND
LEADERSHIP OFTEN KNOWN AS
APPEAL. WHICH IS A NATIONAL
HEALTH JUSTICE ORGANIZATION.
SERVING A AND H. P. I. AND
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. ONE TWENTY ONE
EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS JAMES ACTIVE LITTLE CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA PAN
ETHNIC HEALTH NETWORK IN FULL
SUPPORT OF AB. THIRTEEN FIFTY
EIGHT. AND ONE MOMENT WE HAVE A
FEW MORE BY NUMBERS TOGETHER.
ONE TWENTY ONE OH SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
THANK YOU SENIOR JIM RYAN ON
BEHALF OF THE WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT OF
AB THIRTEEN FIFTY EIGHT THANK
YOU. ONE TWENTY ONE FORTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS HEARING THAT A LONGER
REPRESENT HEALTHY HOUSE- WE ARE
IN MERCED ADAM GREAT DISTRICT
AND WE ARE IN FULL SUPPORT OF
AB THIRTEEN FIFTY EIGHT THANK
YOU. NINE TWENTY ONE SEVENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I THINK FIFTEEN
QUIETWOODS PICKET THE PROGRESS
OF THE DISEASE AMERICAN
ORGANIZATION WE ARE NATIONAL
ORGANIZATION WITH A STRONG BASE
IN CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE IN
FULL SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN
FIFTY EIGHT. NINE TWENTY TWO
ZERO ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWENTY TWO OH
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI GOOD AFTERNOON BUT
THE VALUE CHAIN WITH THE
SOUTHEAST ASIA RESOURCE ACTION
CENTER IN STOCKPORT THANK YOU.
NINE TWENTY TWO OH THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BY TWENTY TWO OH THREE YOUR
JEREMY COMMISSION BEFORE SAID.
SACRAMENTO AND WE ARE
TRANSPORTED AB. THIRTEEN FIFTY
EIGHT. NINE TWENTY TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CHRISTIANE
FROM THE ASIAN AND PACIFIC
ISLANDER AMERICAN HEALTH FORUM
BASED OUT OF SACRAMENTO AND WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NINE TWENTY TWO OF TWO. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU THIS IS LIBBY
BENEDICT I'M REPRESENTING THE
WOMEN'S FOUNDATION CALIFORNIA
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTEEN FIFTY EIGHT. ONE
TWENTY TWO OH NINE. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. A
TWENTY TWO OH NINE YOU MAY BE
ON MUTE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AND
ONE MOMENT WE HAVE ONE LAST. MY
NUMBER TOGETHER.
ONE TWENTY TWO
OH EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY TWENTY TWO
OH EIGHT YOU MAY BE ON MUTE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS- COMMITTEE SAID PM I'M
CALLING FROM. ONE OF THE
CALIFORNIA AND I'M THANKFUL.
FOR AND AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS IN THE QUEUE
THANK YOU MODERATOR IS THERE
ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OUR REMOTE VIDEO TESTIMONY ROOM
SCENE NINE ANYONE IN THE ROOM
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION SEEN. QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
MISTER MEDINA- RIGHT AB SEVEN
EIGHT OR ONE SEVENTY SIX WHICH
REQUIRED THE INSTITUTIONS OF
HIGHER EDUCATION HE JUST GAVE
THE DATA. THE BILL JUST AS
IMPORTANT. AND VERY MUCH IN
SUPPORT YEAH HI I HAVE A
QUESTION THAT I DON'T THINK
MISTER MURATSUCHI HELLO THE
ANSWER BUT I'M LOOKING TO STAFF.
IN IN THE- SUFFERING BUT NUMBER
ONE THE TRACKING ABOUT-
ADDITIONAL MAJOR HISPANIC
LATINO. BANISHED ROOFTOP.
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED LOOKS THAT
ADDITIONAL MAJOR HISPANIC
LATINO OR SPANISH GROUPS
INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED TO
MEXICAN MEXICAN AMERICAN
CHICANOS SALVADORIAN OR M. A.
L. SO IF SOMEBODY COULD
ENLIGHTEN ME. IF THERE'S ANY
COMMITTEE STAFF. WHAT IT
REQUIRES TO WANT THAT SORT OF
THAT IS THAT RIGHT. BECAUSE
IT'S NEW TO ME ALL RIGHT JOSE
YOU'RE DYING TO GET OUT AND I
WAS A SPANISH TEACHER. AND I
WAS A SPANISH TEACHER ETHNIC
STUDIES AND CHICANO STUDIES
TEACHER AT THAT YOU'RE GONNA
ASK INDETERMINATE GOING TO
CHECK ON OUR MEXICAN AMERICAN
NO. MATTER AND SO UNLIMITED
LIGHTLY. COMMITTEE STAFF SHARED
WITH ME THAT THAT THAT IS THE
LANGUAGE THAT'S IN THE BILL
CORRECT WHEN I AND I WOULD LIKE
TO KNOW WHAT IT REFERS TO HEY
LET. I'M GOING TO. THE WHERE
WERE ALL GOING TO LEARN
SOMETHING. I MEAN IT WILL BE A
LANGUAGE BUT I'M NOT FAMILIAR
WITH IT MADAM CHAIR PERHAPS ONE
OF THE- WITH THE SPONSOR YEAH
THE WITNESSES MIGHT NOW.
MILLENNIAL YES HI AND SOON
MA'AM IS THAT THE MAYAN
LANGUAGE WITHIN INDIGENOUS
GROUPS AND JUST SO YOU KNOW
THAT THAT THIS AGGREGATED
CATEGORIES WELL AS GUIDED BY
THE AMERICANS ME SURVEY. GOOD
NO I A I. UNEDUCATED I'M SORRY
WE LEARN WE LEARN SOMETHING
EVERY DAY IN THIS JOB THAT'S
FOR SURE I THINK THANK YOU MR
MEDINA. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS C. NINE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOULD YOU LIKE TO QUIT
WELL OBVIOUSLY MR BONTA IS
BILLS ARE MUCH MORE POPULAR
THAN MINE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR HAVE A- THANK YOU. WE HAVE
A MOTION AND A SECOND.
SECRETARY LEE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS PETRIE-NORRIS HI
PETRIE-NORRIS HI PATTERSON.
BURKE BURKE HI GREAT LACKEY
LACKEY HI MEDINA MEDINA I
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ BY. FIVE
ZERO THAT FELL OUT AND LEAVE
THE WORLD EVENTS THANK YOU AND
THAT WE'VE GOT MORE MOVING NOW
ON TO FILE ITEM THIRTEEN A. B.
ELEVEN TWENTY SIX
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT A. B. ELEVEN TWENTY
SIX- REINTRODUCTION OF AB
THIRTY TO FIFTEEN FROM LAST
YEAR THAT WAS PARKED DUE TO.
OUR A BILL LIMITS. OF THIS BILL
WILL ESTABLISH A PERMANENT
STATE COMMISSION ON THE STATE
OF HATE. AND IS INSPIRED BY THE
ASSEMBLY SELECT COMMITTEE ON
THE STATE OF HATE THAT I'VE HAD
THE HONOR OF CHAIRING SINCE ITS
INCEPTION IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
I'M NOT TELLING YOU ANYTHING
YOU DON'T ALREADY KNOW. WHEN I
SAY THAT HATE CRIMES ARE
INCREASING AT AN ALARMING RATE
AROUND THE COUNTRY AND RIGHT
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. TRAGICALLY
THESE HATE CRIMES ARE BECOMING
MORE VIOLENT AND MORE DEADLY
WITH RECORDED INCREASES IN HATE
RELATED HOMICIDES AND VIOLENT
ASSAULTS. ACCORDING TO THE
CENTER FOR THE STUDY OF HATE
AND EXTREMISM IS TWENTY TWENTY
REPORT TO THE NATION. HATE
CRIME TOTALS FOR TWENTY
NINETEEN HIT THEIR HIGHEST
LEVEL IN OVER A DECADE WITH
SEVEN THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED
AND FOURTEEN HATE CRIME
INCIDENTS REPORTED. FBI DATA
REVEALS THAT TWENTY NINETEEN
WAS ALSO THE DEADLIEST YEAR ON
RECORD FOR HATE CRIMES WITH
FIFTY ONE MURDERS A MORE THAN
1100% INCREASE OVER TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. TWENTY NINETEEN ALSO
MARKED THE THIRD STRAIGHT YEAR
THAT HATE CRIME. OTHER THE HATE
CRIME METRIC SURPASSED SEVENTY
ONE HUNDRED INCIDENTS AND IT
WAS THE HIGHEST NUMBER SINCE
THE FBI REPORTED. SEVEN
THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED EIGHTY
THREE INCIDENTS AND TWENTY AND
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT. ANTI
SEMITIC HATE CRIMES ROSE 14%
FROM TWENTY EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY
NINETEEN. IN THE SAME TIME
FRAME ANTI LATINO HATE CRIMES
ROSE EIGHT POINT 7% AND ANTI
ARAB HATE CRIMES ROSE SIXTEEN
PERCENT. IN TWENTY TWENTY ANTI
AGING ASIAN. HATE CRIMES SURGED
BY ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY NINE
PERCENT. AND HATE CRIMES
AGAINST GAY MEN JUMPED NEARLY
30% TO SEVENTY CRIMES AND ANTI
TRANSGENDER HATE CRIMES ROSE
ABOUT 26% BLACK PEOPLE REMAIN
THE NUMBER ONE TARGET FOR HATE
CRIMES IN AMERICA AT TWICE THE
LEVEL THEY REPRESENT IN THE
POPULATION. WELL WE HAVE SOME
DATA ON THE NUMBER AND TYPE OF
HATE CRIMES THAT ARE BEING
PERPETRATED EXPERTS SAY THAT
THE FBI DATA LIKELY UNDERCOUNTS
THE NUMBER OF HATE CRIMES IN
AMERICA. BOTH BECAUSE MANY
VICTIMS FAILED TO REPORT
INCIDENTS AND LOCAL AGENCIES
ARE NOT REQUIRED TO REPORT HATE
CRIME DATA TO THE FBI. THE FBI
IT RELIES ON THE VOLUNTARY
REPORTING OF MORE THAN FIFTEEN
THOUSAND. PARTICIPATING LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES ACROSS TE
COUNTRY LAST YEAR 86% OF THEM
DID NOT REPORT A SINGLE HATE
CRIME. INCLUDING AT LEAST
SEVENTY ONE CITIES WITH
POPULATIONS OVER ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND ACCORDING TO THE ANTI
DEFAMATION LEAGUE THE SIKH
COALITION AND OTHER ADVOCACY
GROUPS. DUE TO THE STAGGERING
STATISTICS AND CHALLENGES OF
MONITORING COLLECTING AND
ANALYZING THIS DATA IT'S CLEAR
THAT CALIFORNIA NEEDS BETTER
TOOLS AND DEDICATED INDIVIDUALS
TO HELP US TRACK AND REPORT
THIS INFORMATION. THE
COMMISSION ON THE STATE OF HATE
WILL MONITOR AND ASSESS CURRENT
TRENDS RELATIVE TO HATE CRIMES
PRODUCE ANNUAL REPORTS ON THESE
TRENDS AND MAKE POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
LEGISLATURE THE GOVERNOR AND
RELEVANT STATE AGENCIES AND
DEPARTMENTS. IN ORDER TO HELP
THE STATE BE AWARE OF ADDRESS
AND HOPEFULLY REDUCE INSTANCES
OF THESE CRIMES. THE COMMISSION
WILL ALSO HOST COMMUNITY FORMS
IN ORDER TO ENGAGE AND INFORM
THE PUBLIC ON CURRENT TRENDS
AND RECEIVE COMMUNITY FEEDBACK.
THE COMMISSION IS NECESSARY IN
ORDER TO FULLY UNDERSTAND WHO
IS PERPETRATING THESE CRIMES
WHO IS BEING TARGETED AND HOW
WE CAN DEVELOP MOST IMPORTANTLY
I WOULD SAY. HOW WE CAN DEVELOP
POLICY SOLUTIONS TO ADDRESS AND
REDUCE THE INSTANCES OF THESE
CRIMES. AND PLEASED TO HAVE
PROFESSOR BRIAN LEVIN DIRECTOR
OF THE CENTER FOR THE STUDY OF
HATE AND EXTREMISM AT CSU
SAMBAR TO DINO AND MA HA ALGONA
ID. THE CHIEF INNOVATION
OFFICER AT THE ISLAMIC NETWORKS
GROUP WHO WILL BE TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN TWENTY SIX.
THANK YOU. BLOOM MODERATOR CAN
YOU PLEASE CONNECT US WITH
PROFESSOR LEVIN. PROFESSOR
LEVIN FIND IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MADAM CHAIR AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TODAY JOSH. JOSH
TODAY WE RELEASED A STUDY WITH
BRAND NEW DATA UP ON THE
TERRIBLE SCOURGE OF HATE CRIMES
AFFECTING ASIAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITY IN LOS ANGELES FIRST
QUARTER YOU WERE MORE IN VERY
EASILY HE CRIMES IN THE FIRST
QUARTER TWENTY TWENTY ONE. ALL
OF PRE PANDEMIC YOUR TWENTY
NINETEEN ANDWE ARE SEEING
SIMILAR INCREASES IN SAN
FRANCISCO AS WELL AS OTHER
CITIES IN V. ABU. AMONG THE
CITIES THAT HAVE THE LARGEST
ASIAN AMERICAN POPULATION
REALIZE STATE UP IN THE TOP YOU
WE HAVE- DOES HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. SURE THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT IS VERY RELEVANT
AND VERY GOOD AND FAST CHANGING
JUST YESTERDAY THE ADL. OF
FOUND IN THEIR MOST RECENT
REPORT THAT EVEN LOW OUR
RESEARCH HAS SHOWN A DECLINE IN
ANTI SEMITIC. ATTACKS LAST YEAR.
NOW DO PER. YOU THE RISK ON
RELATED TO COLD. AND WHAT IT
WILL BE SEEN SINCE WE SEEN
INCREASE SO THIS IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT. PIECE OF LEGISLATION.
HEY EXTREMISM THREATS TO DATE
EVEN CREATIVELY REGIONAL AND
HOMEGROWN ALTHOUGH IT DOES HAVE
AN INTERNATIONAL DIMENSION WITH
BRITAIN'S WHITE SUPREMACIST
CONNECTING ACROSS. EUROPE. AND
EVEN HERE IN CALIFORNIA. THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WHICH WOULD
ALLOW THE MINISTRATION. NOT
TAKES SERIOUSLY THE CHILDREN
AND WOOD RIGHT RELATED TO HATE
CRIME AND EXTREMISM IS NOW
PLAYING CATCH UP AND WHAT WE
HAVE IS A SWITCH WE'RE WE ARE
HAVING A COMBINATION OF OUR-
REQUIREMENTS MIXED IN WITH.
OTHER TYPES OF TRADITIONAL
GROUP AREIF YOUR GROUP BY.
CALL NOW OR HOW DO YOU CHANGE
WITH GROUPS THAT ARE TARGETED
IN THAT DECADE WE SAW A SURGEON
HE CRIMES AGAINST OUR MUSLIM
AMERICAN BROTHERS AND SISTERS
TO THE EXTENT THAT ASSAULTS.
WERE HIGHER. THAN THE POST NINE
ELEVEN PERIOD. WHAT WE NEED NOW
AND OTHER STATES ARE DOING
ILLINOIS IS DOING IT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS LOOKING
AT DOING IT IS TO CREATE SOME
KIND OF PERMANENT RESOURCE THAT
THE COMBINATION OF DIVERSE
STAKEHOLDERS SUCH AS PEOPLE
FROM THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF HUMAN RELATIONS
ORGANIZATIONS OF WHICH I'M A
MEMBER THAT CONSIST OF NEWMAN
RELATIONS ORGANIZATIONS BUT
ALSO ADVOCACY GROUPS. COMMUNITY
LEADERS AND SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTS INDEED IN CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE DIVERSE EXPERTISE JUDGE
THE OTHER WEEK WE HAD TWO
REFERENCES ON THE FUNDS HAD
MULTIPLE REFERENCES RATHER ON
THE FOR THE SENATE TO
CALIFORNIA BASED. ACADEMIC
INSTITUTIONS THE STOCK API HERE
WITHIN THE STATE AND AN ARTS
CENTER AND WHAT WE HAVE SEEN
ACROSS THE STATE WE HAVE
UNIVERSITIES BOTH PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE FROM STANFORD USC G. U.
S. T. TO THE CALIPHATE DO YOU
SEE IS WHAT THIS KIND OF
EXPERTISE AND BEAT. A STUDY
DONE YEARS AGO SHOWS TO BE THE
ACADEMIC COMMUNITIES. HAVE A
RELATIONSHIP WITH LOCAL
RELATIONS COMMISSION AND
ADVOCACY GROUP LIAISON WHICH
WHICH MAKES AN INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT IS ALREADY. THANK. YOU BUT
NEEDS A PERMANENT HOME. OPIANT
WE ALL SEEN OUR- LEGISLATE
LEGISLATORS. IT BIG DO
WONDERFUL THINGS GET A TURNED
OUT FOR A THREE YEAR ELEVEN
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE HAS
MANY JUST WRAP IT UP IN ABOUT
FIFTEEN. ABSOLUTELY CURRENT
GROUPS ARE INCREASING WE A SET
OF STEAK STAY AND SUBJECT
MATTER EXPERTS ALONG WITH
COMMUNITY GROUPS TO BE ABLE TO
ACT QUICKLY AND RAPIDLY
CHANGING ENVIRONMENT WHEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT STATISTICS ARE
BECOMING A LOT MORE RAPIDLY
AVAILABLE AND MORE TRANSPARENT
BUT WE NEED COMMUNITY MEMBERS
WITNESSED NOT LAW ENFORCEMENT
WE VIGOROUSLY SUPPORT AND I
VOTE FOR THIS IMPORTANT PIECE
OF LEGISLATION THAT IS NEEDED
NOW MORE THAN EVER THANK YOU
FOR YOUR INVITATION TO ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE COULD. THANK YOU
PROFESSOR AT MODERATOR IF YOU
CAN NOW PLEASE CONNECT US WITH.
MY HOT AGAIN NINETY. AND THE
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
INVITATION TO SPEAK WITH YOU
TODAY AND I'M REALLY IMPRESSED
BY THE FACT THAT EVERYONE AS
PRONOUNCE MY LAST NAME-
CORRECTLY SO APPRECIATE THAT-
SO I'M HERE TO SUPPORT- AB
ELEVEN TWENTY SIX IN THE
CREATION OF A COMMISSION ON THE
STATE OF HATE IN CALIFORNIA.
ACCORDING TO- ADDITIONAL RIGHTS
GROUP REPORT THAT WAS JUST
RELEASED THIS WEEK BASED ON
REPORTED INCIDENCES ONLY. ANTI
MUSLIM HATE INCIDENCES
NATIONALLY ROSE BY 9% FROM TWO
THOUSAND AND NINETEEN. OCT TWO
TWO THOUSAND AND TWENTY AND IN
THE SAME ORGANIZATION OVER
SIXTY ONE HUNDRED CASES. WERE
REPORTED THAT INCLUDED HATE
CRIMES DISCRIMINATION BULLYING
IN SCHOOLS. UP POLICE AND
GOVERNMENT OUT OVER REACHING
CASES IN IMMIGRATION AND
TRAVEL- IT'S IMPORTANT TO KNOW
THAT ANTI MUSLIM HATE CRIMES
OFTEN FOLLOW. RHETORIC THE BI
NATIONAL FIGURES IN MEDIA AND
GOVERNMENT AS WELL BRIAN
POINTED OUT ANTI MUSLIM ABOUT
THE TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN DURING
PRESIDENT OF THE PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN. REACHED NINE ELEVEN
OUT LEVELS. AND YOU WERE FROM
HATE CRIMES ALSO FOLLOW
INTERNATIONAL NEWS ABOUT WARS-
THAT YOU THAT THE US IS
INVOLVED IN INTERNATIONAL OR
DOMESTIC TERROR ATTACKS OR
ATTACKS. ON MOSQUES IN OTHER
PARTS OF THE WORLD WILL BE TO
HATE CRIMES HERE IN THE UNITED
STATES AND IN LIGHT OF EMERGING
TRENDS. IN IN THE IN THE RISE
IN WHITE ETHNO NATIONALISM HERE
AND AROUND THE WORLD AND HATE
SPEECH BY THE RIGHT. WE DON'T
BELIEVE THAT HE CRIED WILL BE
UPDATED SOON ESPECIALLY DUE TO
THE PHENOMENAL CALLED
ISLAMOPHOBIA WHICH IS ANTI
MUSLIM RACISM. ISLAMOPHOBIA IS
A WIDE ACROSS MANY AND SOCIETY
THAT IN SCHOOL HIGHER EDUCATION
MEDIA HOLYWOOD VIDEO GAMES
SOCIAL MEDIA. ESPECIALLY
INTERNET WEBSITE AND OF COURSE
IN FEDERAL GOVERNMENT POLICIES
BOTH DOMESTIC AND FOREIGNWE
ALSO HAVE THE ISLAMOPHOBIA
INDUSTRY THAT IS FUNDED BY
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS. TO CONTINUE TO
PRODUCE. A VITRIOLIC MATERIAL
AGAINST UP AGAINST MY PHONE.
FINALLY FROM A PHOBIA- ALSO
DOESN'T JUST IMPACT MUSLIMS BUT
ALSO OF GROUPS THAT ARE THOUGHT
TO BE MOST FUNDS WHICH INCLUDE
ARABS AT THE VAST MAJORITY OF
ARABS IN THIS COUNTRY ARE
CHRISTIAN. SOME OF YOU MAY
ALREADY KNOW IT IMPACTS US SEEK
AND OTHER GROUPS. LIKE HINDUS
THE LATINOS LATINOS AND WHY HE
CRIMES AGAINST MUSLIMS SHOULD
BE- SHOULD BE BETTER TRACK SO
WE ABSOLUTELY SUPPORT THE
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON THE
STATE OF HATE. AND WE HOPE VERY
MUCH THAT BRIAN LEVIN WILL BE
VERY MUCH CENTRAL TO THAT SINCE
THE- SAID HIS ORGANIZATION DOES
A GREAT JOB- TRACKING THAT
SPELL THANK YOU. THEY YOU. A
WITH THAT OUR MODERATOR YOU CAN
OPEN UP THE LINES FOR ANY
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY AND EITHER
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF AB
ELEVEN TWENTY SIX YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
LINE TWENTY TWO THIRTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DANNY MARTIN ON BEHALF OF THE
QUALITY CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
NINE TWENTY FIFTY ONE. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS MADISON DO COSTS WITH
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER CALLING IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
NINE TWENTY TWO TEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M
SORRY AT NINE TWENTY TWO TWELVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO IS THAT ME YES GO
AHEAD PLEASE OKAY YEAH I'D
ENOUGH THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS JUST MECHANICS.
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES AFRICAN AMERICAN
WOMEN'S POLITICAL ACTION
COMMITTEE AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND WE
THANK ASSEMBLYMEMBER GOLFERS
LEADERSHIP. NINE TWENTY TWO
TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
ONE MOMENT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS A LEAP IN SHOCK I'M FROM
WEST SO CALIFORNIA I'M AN
ISRAELI AMERICAN AND I SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU. NINE
TWENTY TWO NINETEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
TWENTY TWO NINETEEN YOU MAY BE
ON MUTE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND MOVING ON.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. MY TWENTY
TWO ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS VERA RASKIN I'M FROM
WESTVILLE CALIFORNIA I'M A
JEWISH AMERICAN AND I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT ANTI SEMITISM
AND I SUPPORT AB ONE ONE TWO
THANK. NINE TWENTY TWO FOURTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY TWENTY TO FOURTEEN
YOU MAY BE ON MUTE PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE
TWENTY TWO SEVENTEEN. ONE
MOMENT. YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI JOHNNY
BENCH NOT SOMETHING CALABASAS
CALIFORNIA HEARING I PUT A
SPELL DALY MACKEN AND VERY
CONCERNED THANK YOU. NINE
TWENTY TWO TEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THIS IS JOHN CALLING ON BEHALF
OF IBM CALIFORNIA IN. THIS BILL
OKAY. ONE TWENTY TWO TWENTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
MICHAEL BIGELOW. HELLO
CALIFORNIA MISSOURI AMERICAN
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT ANTI
SEMITISM. NINE TWENTY TWO OH
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS SANDY
MARCHAND FROM NORTHRIDGE
CALIFORNIA I'M THRILLED
AMERICANS I'M VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT AND I THINK COULD NOT
SUPPORT. EIGHTY ONE ONE TWO
SIX. ONE TWENTY TWO TWENTY
SEVEN. YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
ESTHER REPEAT FROM WHAT THE
HELL CALIFORNIA I'M AN ISRAELI
AMERICAN AND I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT ANTI SEMITISM LIKE THE
COURT AT. ELEVEN TWENTY SIX.
NINE TWENTY TWO EIGHTEEN. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS HANNAH PROPANE
COMPANY VALLEY CALIFORNIA AND
ISRAELI AMERICAN AND I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT AND
ENTERTAINMENT WITH AS WELL AS
THE COURT ITSELF. NINE TWENTY
TWO THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS GINA RAMI I'M CALLING
FROM SHERMAN OAKS I'M ISRAELI
AMERICAN I'M ALL ITEMS FROM THE
CONCERNED ABOUT ANTI SEMITISM
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL. NINE
TWENTY TWO TWENTY. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES HI MY
NAME IS SONYA BEEN STUCK ON
OPENS EARLY AMERICAN VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT ANTI SEMITISM
AND I SUPPORT THE BILL THANK
YOU. THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENT IN THE QUEUE. THANK YOU
MODERATOR UP WITH THAT ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES WISHING TO
TESTIFY FROM THE REMOTE VIDEO
CENTER NOW. I SEE NINE ANYONE
IN THE HEARING ROOM WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN EITHER SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION SEEING NONE BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MEDINA. I WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR. I'VE HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF BEING ON THE
SELECT COMMITTEE ON THE STATE
OF HATE AND THE HEARINGS THAT
WE'VE HAD. ACROSS THE STATE AT
UCLA CAL STATE SAN BERNARDINO.
AND- PROBABLY NOT MUCH MORE
NEEDS TO BE SAID ABOUT THE
TIMELINESS OF THIS BILL AND I
JUST THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING IT FORWARD AND FOR HIS
DEDICATION AND ALL HIS TIME
HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE. ON ON
COMBATING HATE AS IT PERTAINS
TO ALL GROUPS. THANK YOU. YEAH.
I WOULD JUST ADD THE ODDS THAT
THE STATISTICS THAT YOU SHARED
IN YOUR OPENING COMMENTS THAT
THE WITNESSES SHARED IT'S
ABSOLUTELY HORRIFYING WE ALL
KNOW THAT WE HAVE SEEN A REALLY
PRECIPITOUS RISE IN HATE CRIMES
AND HATE INCIDENCES ALL ACROSS
THE COUNTRY ACROSS OUR STATE
AND SADLY AND IN MANY OF OUR
OWN COMMUNITIES I'M SO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MEDINA SAID THIS IS VERY
TIMELY AND I TO JUST WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
ON THIS REALLY IMPORTANT ISSUE
AND DEATH. WITH THAT WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU ALL A
ADOPT YOUR STATEMENTS MY
CLOTHES. THE EXCEPTION OF THE A
FINAL PARTS- AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR FIVE A- THANK YOU
FIVE I THINK WE NEED A MOTION
AND- OUR MOTION FROM
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BURKE AND SECOND
FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE WE CALL
THE ROLL. THIS IS A DO PASS AND
REFERRED TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS PETRIE-NORRIS HI
PETRIE-NORRIS HI PATTERSON.
BURKE AND ALLY MAKE MOMENTS
WITH THE FAMILY MEMBER MEDINA
AND- ASSEMBLY MEMBER BURKE HI
GREAT. BLACKIE LACKEY I MEDINA
MEDINA HI RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I.
THANK YOU FIVE FIVE ZERO THAT
PHYLLIS OUT AND LEAVE THE ROLL
UP AND FOR OTHERS TO ADD ON
THANK YOU YOU'RE WELCOME THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND THAT NEXT
ITEM ON THE AGENDA LET'S MOVE
TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR THERE
ARE THREE BELLS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR TODAY AB THIRTEEN
TWENTY THREE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHIU AB FOURTEEN TWENTY NINE
FROM ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN. AB
EIGHT FIFTEEN SEVENTY ONE WHICH
IS A COMMITTEE BELL FROM THE
JOBS ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT THE
ECONOMY COMMITTEE. IS THERE ANY
MEMBER WISHING TO PULL AN ITEM
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR SAY
NONE. I DO WE HAVE A MOTION AND
A SECOND. MOTION FOR
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BURKE SECOND
FROM ASSEMBLYMEMBER LACKEY.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION FOR ALL THREE
THERE IS DO PASS AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. PETRIE-NORRIS
HI PETRIE-NORRIS I PATTERSON.
BURKE BURKE AYE GRAIN. LACKING
LACKEY I MEDINA MEDINA I
RODRIGUEZ GLOBAL TO GET ONLINE
FIVE ZERO AND LEAVE THAT ALSO
OPEN FOR OTHERS TO ADD ON THAT
DOES CONCLUDE OUR BUSINESS BUT
WE WILL OPEN UP THAT WE'RE
GOING TO IT AT IF THE CALL ON
THE BILLS THAT WE CAN ENABLE
OTHER MEMBERS TO ADD ON. FOR AB.
TWO BLACKIE BLACKIE I RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ I. ALL RIGHTS ARE.
WITH HER WOULD. THAT'S WHAT WE
YOU CAN BE DIFFERENT I BET THAT
IS OUT WITH FIVE ZERO WILL
LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR OTHER
MEMBERS TO ADD ON. AB FOR
TWELVE RODRIGUEZ. RODRIGUEZ I.
FOR FIVE ZERO WE'LL LEAVE THAT
CONTINUE TO LEAVE IT OPEN. AB
FOUR SIXTEEN LACKEY. LACKEY NO
RODRIGUEZ. RODRIGUEZ I. AT FOUR
ZERO SO THAT BILL IS ONE I'M
SORRY I'M- FOUR ONE I BELIEVE
THAT OPEN FOR OTHERS TO ADD ON.
AB FIVE EIGHTY ONE LACKEY
LACKEY I RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I.
FIVE ZERO WELL BELIEVE ALL
THESE HAVE BEEN FURTHER DATA.
AB EIGHT OH NINE LACKEY LACKEY
I. FIVE ZERO. A. B. SIX SIX
ONE. RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I.
FIVE ONE FOUR ONE. HANDLE EVEN
IF. A. B. SEVEN SEVEN SEVEN
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I. FIVE
ZERO WE CANNOT OPEN. AB EIGHT
NINE THREE FOUR RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ I. FIVE ZERO. AND
WITH THAT WE WILL RE OPEN. THE
BILL'S ON CALL TO ENABLE OTHER
MEMBERS TO ADD ON. MADAM
SECRETARY. A. B. TO. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FONG FONG IS THE AUTHOR.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PATTERSON
PATTERSON I. I THINK THE COLORS
AND THE NUMBER VERY WITH
ASSEMBLY APESAR HE SAID
ASSEMBLY HE SAID ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PATTERSON ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GRAY SORRY I JUST HAVE
TO CALL EVERY MEMBER. STILL
ABLE TO FROM A FAMILY MEMBER
GRAY I'LL JUST CALL FAMILY
MEMBERS BRING. THEM IMMIGRANT
OKAY. OKAY SEVEN ZERO ON THAT
ONE. THAT AB FOR TWELVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER READ. THE
PATTERSON HE FINISHED TO VOTE
ON THIS ONE THANKS SEVEN THREE
NINETY NINE FIX PATTERSON AND
THE GREAT ABOUT THE FIFTH GRADE
FOR. OKAY WELL WHAT THE OPTICS
OF THE REDUCTION PLAN. AB. FOR
TWELVE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PATTERSON PATTERSON I ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GRAY. NUMBER GREAT HI.
AB FOUR SIXTEEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PATTERSON. ARE WE HERE FOR
SIXTEEN. PATTERSON NOW GREAT
RIGHT NOW. RIGHT THAT'S FOR
THREE. ONE AB FIVE EIGHTY ONE
PATTERSON PATTERSON I GREAT
GREAT I. AT. SEVEN ZERO. A. B.
EIGHT OH NINE PATTERSON
PATTERSON I GREAT GREAT I. AB
SIX SIX ONE A PATTERSON
PATTERSON NOW. GREAT. GREAT I.
FIVE TWO. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PATTERSON. SEVEN EIGHT FOUR YES
AB SEVEN SEVEN SEVEN. PATTERSON
I GREAT EIGHT I. SEVEN ZERO. AB.
NINE TWENTY THREE. PATTERSON
PATTERSON I GREAT. GREAT I.
SEVEN ZERO. AB NINE THREE FOUR
PATTERSON. THANK YOU FOR YOUR-
PATTERSON I GREAT GREAT I.
SEVEN ZERO. AB ELEVEN TWENTY
SIX PATTERSON PATTERSON I GREAT
GREAT I. SEVEN ZERO AB THIRTEEN
FIFTY EIGHT PATTERSON- SINCE I
GREAT GREAT I AND THEN FOR THE
CONSENT CALENDAR WHICH IS. A.
B. THIRTEEN TWENTY THREE A. B.
FOURTEEN TWENTY NINE AB.
FIFTEEN SEVENTY ONE. PATTERSON
PATTERSON I GREAT. GREAT I AM
WONDERFUL THANK YOU GENTLEMEN
THAT CONCLUDES OUR BUSINESS
TODAY AND- WITH THAT I WILL
DURING TODAY'S HEARING OF THE
ASSEMBLY IS ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW COMMITTEE.
YEAH THAT'S RIGHT NOW.